we live baby
everybody shut up we're making art are
you enjoying this content right now is
that what you say before you start
recording content i shouldn't even
notice what you're doing it's so weak
we're in a new studio you can shout gone
can you give us an example content oh my
god
hello gamers welcome back to another
episode of the trash taste podcast i am
boy with boys you guys know us by now
and we have a themed episode as you can
tell
we've never done this we've never done
this like like imagine this what if we
make a three by three guys never done
that before before have you heard of an
episode that will not go on a tangent
i'm just kidding we will go well i think
because we're me and gartner plans to go
out to the uk for a bit so we need to
record a little more epic episodes in
advance so our solution to that is
themed episodes so that we don't have we
don't run out of stuff to talk about we
don't run ourselves but i like the three
by three episodes right because it's
just it's just a good excuse to talk
about [ __ ] that maybe we're not gonna
ever tangent towards it's just hilarious
that we kind of brought back the three
by three like not the three of us i
didn't even i didn't even know it was a
thing yeah right i don't even know if
it's people haven't done since like 2010
but anyway we've done a couple of three
by three episodes in the past we did one
on anime yeah uh we've done one on games
yep and i think this will be the third
one now we're gonna talk about
movies not anime movies yeah actual
live-action movies with real people
people because i feel like we don't have
to [ __ ] specify we watch real movies
well yeah of course because to some
people it's like oh so so so nine ghibli
films is that is that gonna be honestly
like i don't i don't get to talk about
live-action movies a lot even though i
feel like i've watched a hell of a lot
of live-action movies but yeah the
biggest problem i had when making this
three by three was i don't remember what
the [ __ ] i've watched well if you've
been watching movies god knows how long
my entire life there's no like my movie
listening yeah i feel like when you
got into anime specifically it was
probably a point where you really like
cared about it a lot yeah yeah what i
mean so you made note of what you're
watching yeah yeah yeah you've been
watching movies your whole goddamn life
because this is what you do well didn't
you go through like the imdb top 200 or
whatever i went through to remind myself
all right what have i seen okay i know
yeah i like that that one's good but
it's on my face i literally had to go
down that list to remind myself what
i've seen and what yes okay so what like
what logic did you guys use to choose
your three by threes okay so in my head
i always have like a top three movies
ready because you know yeah you're
always going to be asking hey what's
your favorite movies i always have like
a top three but three by three you need
nine movies right so i'm like all right
[ __ ]
all right i'll fill in the rest of the
six with like movies that i thought were
really good that i want to recommend to
people yeah or movies that i know i've
seen multiple times and i'll keep
watching multiple times yeah my mine
were not recommendations at all i was
thinking uh maybe i'll just make the
ones where like the movies i really
really like and then i just like i just
i just went through like my list of
movies i really liked and i just like
too many [ __ ] movies yeah right i
literally could not narrow it down it it
needs to be like a [ __ ] top 50 list
like i've seen most of the imdb top 100
i was like this isn't not helping it
would just literally just be like the
imdb top 200 most of the time so like i
just went [ __ ] that what are the movies
that i've just seen the most and like if
it's if it's on tv i'm just like i got
time to watch this movie i don't know i
just i just pick movies with me think of
something
feel feel things i don't know an aurora
movie that gave me an experience yeah i
mean i i feel that i because yeah i feel
like the problem with that for me is
that too many movies do that for me so
it's like you're out here like [ __ ]
having an emotional breakdown every
movie you watch i like movies i like
movies i always just i also it's really
hard also to like get rid of recency
bias as well yeah like immediately i
thought of like the last 10 movies i
watched and i'm like were they as
memorable yeah as these other movies
that i probably haven't seen in like
five ten years i must say there's some
movies on my list that i haven't seen in
[ __ ] years and i've put them on just
because i can't i wasn't sure about
movies
i was like i was like obsessed with them
as a kid yeah yeah so some of those are
on the my list so the [ __ ]
teletubbies movie
how far back we talking here pretty far
back you'll see so let's see if our
movie tastes are as pretentious as our
anime tastes yeah uh but we're gonna
decide as always with trash box [ __ ] to
see who goes first
that was a genuine bit all right who
wants to pick who goes first i'll go
first
i hope it's not me you gave i really
don't want to go first
oh thank god it's gone
thank god it's gone oh [ __ ] i didn't
want to go first bring up guards 3x3
okay
so your logic for your three by three
was
that
oh my god
this is why i didn't want to go first
because i got it
i've gotta [ __ ] defend this [ __ ]
okay there are some there are some there
where i'm like okay okay genuinely good
movies and then there's uh
okay so so this this is split into two
parts i just have our space jams in the
[ __ ] middle yeah like it's like okay
this is my movie as a [ __ ] kid walk
like as a kid who grew up in the 90s
that everyone went through a [ __ ]
space jam face this is a classic okay
it's a [ __ ] classic i mean i didn't
as a kid i didn't watch the [ __ ] nba
didn't even watch the [ __ ] looney
tunes and even as the as a kid i [ __ ]
watch this so many times every time it
was on tv i've rewatched this [ __ ] so
much space jam's amazing it's a good
movie it's not like a kid trying to
justify you [ __ ] on the bed
like your parents
do you want to go through your list all
right so
okay
so kung fu hustle
all right that's good
that's a good movie that's great movie
rush hour
yo i [ __ ] love rush hour yeah
uh memento yeah scott pilgrim versus the
world feeling you're gonna put memento
over something i don't know why yeah i
don't know because i was that close to
putting momentum
like this i feel god's gonna put memento
i don't know why
um space jam of course the matrix first
matrix right yeah the first match okay
good the four year old version
uh snatch and confessions so this is
very much split up into my childhood
obsession movies and then some movies
that i just want people to watch and
recommend and that's why i've just
watched it so many times okay so before
we i guess which movies have you seen
joey here i've seen all of them except
for kung fu hustle and confessions i've
not seen snatch sounds so familiar
snatch the one where this one where he
[ __ ] is like a boxer right yeah it's
not just a guy rich movie it's a good
movie i think i think it's i think it's
guy richie's best movie like by far it's
that and lock stock and i was thinking
about putting a quentin tarantino movie
on but i'm surprised there is no quentin
tarantino
okay i had a feeling someone else was
going to put it on okay so that's why uh
that's why i put on snatch instead of
quentin tarantino because it's like
snatch and like reservoir dogs which is
like my quentin tarantino move your
choice it's kind of like it's kind of
like the same kind of field for me yeah
and i feel like more people have know
about quentin tarantino which is why i
wanted to put snatch which is kind of
like if you want kind of a british
quentin tarantino kind of movie where
it's just it's just like it's just got
amazing dialogue and i love i love the
concept of a lot of different characters
have that's nothing to do with uh that
has nothing to do with each other just
kind of like merging in into one
coherent storyline and uh there's just
bands there's the banter in this is so
[ __ ] good that i still quote this to
this day like so many of the lines i
come up with just comes from snatch
because
it's just got great writing great
[ __ ] humor wow geek literally
stealing from snapchat yeah i haven't
seen confessions oh me neither i've
never even heard confessions is actually
a japanese movie right
um
i know and it's
it's the one movie
i've read
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay um i didn't
know it was even based on the book but
it's
probably my favorite revenge movie of
all time i think it's a miyabi book is
the one where it's like set in high
school yeah with like two girls
kind of kind of think so
so the concept of this movie um is uh
the main character's a teacher right
yeah and she used to teach
uh teacher class right and
so these two students from these class
or i i think it's like two or three
students from this class they basically
uh they basically murder her
uh her daughter yeah um but because of
japanese laws if you're like a miner
then you can't be charged even if you've
technically like killed somebody right
we're just [ __ ] yeah yeah which of
which is [ __ ] and that's like the
whole premise of this movie yeah and the
premise of this movie is just her
basically playing [ __ ] 5d chess
against these high schoolers and just
coming up with a very unique like
revenge scheme against these kids right
and it's kind of it's kind of like maybe
similar to old boy if you've seen old
boy but maybe just maybe just not as
[ __ ] yeah i think uh i i think that's
pretty [ __ ] up yeah old boys pretty
[ __ ] and my problem with old boy is
that i'm surprised old boy isn't on your
three by the way well my problem with
old boys i really liked it but there are
definitely some parts of old boy that
really push your suspension of disbelief
like like uh without spoiling like
without spoiling the ending of old boy
or something there's some plot elements
where you're just like final twist yeah
like the final twist where you're just
yeah
the final twist where you just like
yeah
can the human mind be tricked into doing
this yeah that's like kind of pushing it
what i like about confessions is that
it's kind of like the same kind of deal
where it's one person look uh
getting revenge over people yeah but
it's just it's kind of like she's kind
of like a light yagami lelouch kind of
character where she it's it's a very
it's a very intricate revenge
but it's believable yeah and it's it's i
mean it's believable because the whole
premise is [ __ ] to begin with because
this is real like you know japanese
miners cannot be charged even if they
kill somebody and that's that's like the
premise of the movie but um the way it
unravels
is really really interesting and um for
a japanese movie as well one of the
biggest things i remember when watching
this movie for the first time is that
out of nowhere they start playing
radiohead
hell yeah and i'm just like is that
[ __ ] radiohead i'm listening to now
and so radiohead is
like literally one of the best parts of
this movie was just like you know like
the the song for like the epic reveal
where she reveals everything yeah it's
just [ __ ] radiohead and i'm just like
this is this is the best reveal i've
ever seen in the movie wait which
radiohead song is it um i i can't
remember it's oh yeah yeah yeah it's
it's not a face remember the emotions i
just remember the emotions man it's not
it's not the most famous radiohead songs
right
yeah it's it's it's the one movie that i
think is like really underground because
it's a japanese movie uh and i everyone
who's watched it so far has been really
really [ __ ] impressed and i don't see
many people talking about this movie
because yeah i feel like japanese cinema
uh japanese cinema in general just gets
looked over a lot but i feel like
because they tackle very japanese things
more often than not yeah the way they go
about things is very japanese and like
kind of like doesn't really make well
not that doesn't make sense but kind of
odd yeah there's a lot of like cultural
elements and like things that they throw
back to that where other people feel
like oh that doesn't happen in my school
yeah you have to kind of like just look
past a lot of things i think when you
watch japanese movies or foreign
yeah because like i've i've definitely
read this book before and i really
really enjoyed like back in like high
school as well i think it's quite an old
book but um
yeah i mean for one i didn't even know
that this was like a movie first of all
yeah i didn't even know it was available
in english because like a lot of
japanese cinema doesn't make it outside
of japan but like there's always
translations online oh yeah of course
but it's like i don't know i i just
wasn't expecting this yeah yeah like i i
recommend a lot of movies from this
director i can't remember his name but
confession is my favorite one the
posters memories memories of matsuko is
another movie that this director made
that is like really underground even for
like japanese cinema but it's [ __ ]
amazing okay um but yeah just
like if you if you're gonna take
anything out of my 3x3 watch confessions
because more people need to know about
confessions kokuhaku um it's an amazing
movie it's one of the few japanese
movies that i think is just easily
accessible to like anyone you don't
really need to know about japanese
culture um it's just a good revenge plot
and it kind of if you like old boy or
you know a lot of korean movies you're
probably gonna like confessions yeah
miyabi miyuki i think is is the original
woman who wrote kokaku right like all of
her books kind of like deal with this
kind of like yeah it's kind of like
criticizing [ __ ] up parts of japan and
like using it as like an advantage right
yeah it's really good yeah the book
sounds really really good yeah yeah
might actually watch it yeah um the best
movie on there is the 40 year old yeah
absolutely i think so honestly i think
i think i've out of because i wanted to
put a comedy movie on i was thinking
what comedy movie can i infinitely
rewatch you've got like three on yeah
you've got scott piller and versus the
world space jam rush hour he's like all
all called pilgrim is a comedy scott
pilgrim's kidding me yeah i guess it's
like a [ __ ] it's a comedy it's
non-stop jokes i mean it's okay okay
it's it's it's just best with visual
comedy yeah it's okay it is definitely a
it's it's a comedy movie but it's not
just girl comedy in there because i love
like i mean like i've 40-year old virgin
it's great story of a man you know
coming to losing virginity yeah of
course it's a great coming of age
yeah and i was thinking like what
because i feel like recently comedy
movies have kind of just died i don't
know if that's the thing what's what's
well i mean
you know it's like it's like they're
like the [ __ ] will ferrell movies and
uh all the modern adam sandler films
outside of uncut gems yeah i've just
[ __ ] made it
yeah that's literally only it yeah but
also the adam sadler movies do extremely
well on netflix and not really some of
the most watched things on netflix the
ones that they bought off i think i've
seen an adam sandler movie since because
they're all so mediocre yeah and the
only one that he he was amazing in which
was uncut gems is absolutely [ __ ]
amazing yeah um it wasn't even his movie
it was some he was just he's the main
actor yeah i've heard
is that a comedy movie or is that just a
movie it's a it's like a pretty pretty
uh brutal movie looking really [ __ ]
good though yeah
all i've seen from that is the clip when
he goes oh my god i'm gonna come
if you haven't it's i think it's his
best role yeah but yeah 40 year old
virgin is like to me the infinitely
rewatchable comedy movie for me that
used to play on british television i
think like once a [ __ ] week no that's
why i've watched it so many times
everyone in the uk has watched it
because you used to play on like
all the [ __ ] time this is also one of
those movies that never leaves the
airplane like exactly always playing
like if you look up movies on an
airplane like the old classics genre
it's always interesting so many famous
scenes in that movie like the [ __ ]
tit scene where they talk about feeling
a boob okay it's like a sandbag
and the [ __ ] waxing scene as well
it's iconic it's iconic and i feel like
this gets talked about less than maybe
like
at least at least when it first came out
because the iconic was that one of his
like most famous like is that one of the
roles that i blew him up this was when i
first started first started to know
steve carell because i didn't know about
him before because i think before that
the only thing i've seen him in was like
bruce or micey yeah but he had like one
iconic scene he wasn't the main
character he wasn't the main character i
mean it was jim carrey yeah um but i
feel like this was his first movie where
i was just like damn this guy is funny
this is a funny [ __ ] movie yeah
probably but i remember back when this
came out um the iconic comedy movie when
this first came out was super bad
classic everyone was like 2 000's humor
like that was yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah everyone
and everyone was quoting super bad and i
was like kind of i kind of think the
four-year-old virgin's funnier that was
just
just me back then i thought super bad
was funny for like
two months no no when you're in high
school superbad is like the funniest
[ __ ] oh yeah it's like it's like you're
just going through it like when you've
heard of like the the you know
thousandth mclovin joke you're just like
all right yeah i get it i get it it's
kind of same with borat right yeah
i mean
actually it's so fun um like uh sydney
had never seen borat before right so
so she watched boar app for the first
time in 2021 about like about like a
month ago okay
and
like
like me someone who's like been quoted
more at throughout my entire high school
it's been quoted to death right
um i i i you know it's hard to find it
funny anymore because it's just been
like everyone's just it's so ingrained
it's so ingrains that i just ceased to
find it funny anymore she still found it
[ __ ] hilarious oh it's so funny
like when i watch that movie all i think
is like god damn he's such a [ __ ]
amazing actor yeah
he is there's app there's no movie that
even comes close to like that kind of
experience
it's crazy admittedly you know like i i
could probably quote most of that movie
but i'd be lying if i said every time i
heard bora go my wife like
i'm like that's just hilarious
because more i said my wife said you
just [ __ ] lost it and i was like oh
[ __ ] this was funny at the point i
forgot that this was legitimately funny
yeah yeah the genius of [ __ ] bar
it like made you on a surface level you
think that oh this is just funny movie
yeah yeah
but it was really just a really [ __ ]
intelligent way of showing how racist
america yeah exactly and that's how good
and the best part was is that those
people were the ones quoting it yeah it
came out exactly but it's like a genius
way of showing it in a way that like he
made a he showed like how like i guess
there was like racist problems in
america before it was like you know
talked about wildly today yeah
and still it was massively marketed
towards the audience and i didn't even
know that that's what he's poking fun at
well that's what well that's what i
[ __ ] loved about ali g back in the
day oh my god that's a name i haven't
heard anything like that there's a movie
as well
yeah like that oh my god like the first
time i watched that like i thought
everything was scripted and like a lot
of it is but like some of the interview
scenes stuff like that it's all
non-scripted i'm like how the [ __ ] does
he do that he's just a genius like being
able to turn a situation and like
make them look stupid yeah without
having to like make them think that he's
playing a character yeah yeah he's so
good at that yeah like he yeah he is
actually like like a social genius
because he knows how to work people so
well yeah and the thing is like
i
i just he gets so invested in his
character
it's actually insane nightmare being
married to him
which character are you tonight honey
like because i remember like re-watching
borat with sydney there was this one
scene where he gets drunk with a bunch
of american frat boys and at first i was
like there's no way this is real this
must be scripted right and so we looked
into it and uh it's totally real to the
point got drunk with them yeah to the
point where he got like blackout drunk
with them and just was able to stay in
character this entire [ __ ] time
that's [ __ ] dedication man it's
insane like so big i think by the time
he goes to do these characters it's so
[ __ ] baked in his head yeah he's this
character that he doesn't even think i i
oh i'm doing an act he's just yeah he
just that's just him he just thinks this
is me yeah she's insane i don't know
it's just it's such an insane maybe you
shouldn't put more out yeah
i didn't put bar on my i wish i did now
because i just like the whole i find it
all so fascinating and like what is
america is so [ __ ] funny as well like
oh he's just so funny yeah he's very
very good absolutely [ __ ] genius yeah
um so aside from that i guess what else
haven't you seen jerry i've seen
everything oh come through hustle i
haven't seen kung fu arsenal [ __ ]
that's that's that stuff's good that's a
[ __ ] banger i mean it looks [ __ ]
awesome it's like i i to me it's like
one of the closest you could possibly
get to real life anime right
it's it's it's somehow wacky
uh it's a wacky live-action kind of
slapstick what it does is that it it
does to parody martial arts movies yeah
it just makes a martial arts movie that
is just an anime right right yeah yeah
all the characters are like i have this
power and then they do like all weird
[ __ ] spells and [ __ ] yeah yeah so
like say like the premise of this movie
is like there's like this like
axe gang right this very famous gang and
for some reason they invade this very
very small village
that nobody's heard of and it's just
like this secret village where
coincidentally a lot of martial arts
masters have just like it's all situated
in this one city
so what happens is firstly they find
three martial arts masters who just
happened to live in the city they didn't
know they lived in the city like one
person was just like the i think like a
barber or something or so
it's been so long yeah but the uh
store oh yeah one was the noodle store
guy the taylor oh the taylor yeah yeah
like the laborer damn you remember the
story you remember this better than me
ashley
and so after they find out these three
martial arts masters are in this uh
village they were like well we got to
send assassins to assassinate them right
so they send assassins to to like get
rid of these three martial arts masters
and then it turns out that there are
even more like higher up martial arts
masters just living in here just living
in there
hierarchy hierarchy pyramid
and so like
they just find out like more op people
just keep [ __ ] invading this village
and they keep like more opie heroes just
keep coming out of the woodworks it's
[ __ ] great it's just literally just
escalation yeah it sounds so good it's
such a funny thing i've never heard of
this movie it's it's really if you watch
martial arts movies yeah which i don't
like i used to yeah you'll know about
this just like it's well that's the
thing like during high school i had like
a massive like spree of just watching
every bruce lee and jack chan movie yeah
and like all the martial arts movies i
could think of same yeah
but i never heard of this one for some
reason yeah i mean i feel like if you
did go through that martial arts phase
this is this is like one of the peak of
just
it's it knows the genre so well that it
kind of parodies itself right but at the
same time takes itself 100 seriously
right right
it's it's just one of the best
that's the best kind of movie yeah yeah
yeah exactly it does everything well for
martial arts movie um and that's why i
love it it's got the wacky fight and
it's got like the really well
choreographed fights as well right um
but speaking of martial arts fights that
defines my childhood
rush hour
yeah speaking of jackie chan there he is
right there what can you say
i i wish there was more russia
i need the dynamic
i really think that the rush hour series
was what got me into the whole martial
arts genre to begin with
yeah i mean honestly maybe same i don't
know it was so funny my friend showed me
it when i was like really young and i
just [ __ ] fell in love with it it was
so fun yeah yeah i mean it's it's a like
jackie chan and chris tucker was is a
dynamic that on paper should never work
they should never have the chemistry
that they do but they have such good
chemistry and the amount of times i've
rewatched rush hour one and two
especially in my childhood it's just
like uncountable i actually don't know
how much how many times i've rewatched
it because it's like it like defined
like a good like five year period of my
life because that was what started my
martial arts phase where i just watched
so many different martial arts movies
chan is
very very funny yeah oh yeah
he's one of the most charismatic actors
i feel like in that that's carried by
jackie chan like how good he is at
playing like dumb yeah yeah yeah he's so
good in this yeah him playing off chris
tucker it's just yeah it's just it's
christmas chris yeah yeah
he's just funny by himself yeah yeah and
jackie chan is also like funny by
himself for like a completely different
reason it's a completely clash of styles
but like i remember when i was doing uh
during the uh not the anime awards the
trash taste awards when uh i was doing
the uh pizza crust i have a dream speech
right yeah people were just like wow
ghan's really uh god's really parodies
martin luther king really well and i'm
just like i actually just took that
speech from rush hour too when chris
tucker did it
all of your [ __ ] uh jokes and
everything come from [ __ ] movies yeah
everything you hear on giger is just
movie quotes
i mean like this is the secret coming
out right when i'm just like these are
the movies i've rewatched so many times
that they're just ingrained in my mind
was rush hour two the best one i think
it was what what was the plot of rush
hour two the paris one no that was rush
hour three that was that was that
rush hour i love how he just immediately
knows it's like yeah that's russia i
can't remember a distinction between any
of them they're all just all of the rush
hours kind of just blend together yeah
yeah um i remember rush hour one and two
were the good ones um
i think three was average three was kind
of like the continuous i mean i mean
jackie chan was getting like a little
bit old when rush hour three happens so
he like you could tell that he couldn't
do as many stunts as he could do rush
hour one and two i feel like was jackie
chan more like he he could get away
um but yeah i remember i don't know why
but i remember as a kid i slightly
preferred rush hour too i think that was
the slightly better movie but i mean
rush hour one is still [ __ ] brilliant
as well i mean can we also just talk
about the fact that i fully expected you
to put memento in your three places yeah
why why it just seems like have i ever
talked about no no it just seems like i
can't i can picture the gig video he's
like it's like guys what if i told you
you could go back and get pictures or
something i just i feel like i i would
hear i was here like
i could i feel like i i can see you
making a video about memento even though
you never have made a movie it just
feels like a gig yeah if i can imagine
anyone making a memento video it's
either you or john
like super i've actually
just seems like the kind of thing you
would talk about it's just like a very
like artsy film i mean it's a really
good film isn't it an artsy film i think
it's an rc film it's a bitter i mean
it's like christopher nolan being
christopher nolan but being like i have
500 iq watch me try to present my 500 iq
on film and it's just like memento is
one of the few like films i think he's
made that actually it's just like oh
that was that was no long that was
pretty smart i i got it
memento actually was written by his
brother
okay yeah it's it's based off like it's
based off like a four-page novella
written by jonathan nolan yeah yeah
christopher was like you have four pages
let me turn that into 400 and get guy
pierce in it yeah because i remember
this was one of his first movies and
they actually i think this was i didn't
know it was based on a novella because i
know that they made a short film around
this which i've actually seen and that's
also really good and they expanded on
this idea um and it's just like
it's just like nolan with no budget like
but still doing the same kind of nolan
ideas like before he had a budget and uh
lieutenant right
it's tenant without a budget
and then tenant happens and then he
forgot that he had to write like
characters and a plot and just like
to go along with the cool ideas
but like i feel like this and inception
i mean inception's been meme to [ __ ] to
like hell and back right yeah yeah yeah
but i i remember the first time i saw
inception i thought it was [ __ ]
amazing of course yeah i mean like i i
will always give nolan a chance just
because his peak he always just
something interesting yeah yeah like he
always
you know even if he doesn't make uh the
best movie he always has interesting
ideas and he always tries something new
which is what i can respect
not everything hits the mark
but it's nolan you can expect that he's
not going to stay in his comfort zone i
mean memento is definitely one of those
movies that like or a you have to watch
more than once to fully understand but b
even after multiple watches it's like
i don't get it yeah so to explain
memento to anyone who hasn't seen it uh
this is yeah it's gonna sound so weird
but it's a movie that plays in reverse
kind of kind of yeah because it's about
this guy who has a condition that gives
him short-term memory loss
so he can only remember at most like
five minutes
something like like what a horrible
existence yeah yeah someone like that in
real life i think actually yeah i think
so yeah i mean this this is an actual
real condition that exists right somehow
they made it into a real thing
oh you can't believe it oh my god i
can't believe you got the same condition
as that guy from memento yeah
but uh so because of this you only
presented like five minutes of this
movie at a time and it's a movie that
plays in reverse and it's about this guy
who has this condition and uh is trying
to get revenge for the person who
murdered his wife which uh which you
know it's uh
combine uh five minute memory uh five
minute short term memory uh with uh long
term revenge plot um things uh that's uh
the thing's about to get confused and
things are gonna get confusing
especially for the main character i
watched this movie i don't know it's the
one where like every time he comes to
again he looks at his body because he
tattoos all his memories
i think i've heard so much about this
movie that i think i've seen it but i
don't actually think i've ever seen it
oh really right everything i have
actually it's very good yeah but i know
the plot and i know what happened yeah
yeah yeah it's just everyone knows the
thoughts because everyone you know what
happens yeah okay so you know the
twister i believe i do yeah yeah yeah i
mean we're not
yeah yeah but i think i know
what the twist is yeah yeah but like i
just remember the first time i've
watched this movie and i'm just like
damn this is
legit like really clever 500 iq meme
aside you know you you don't have to
have a high iq to enjoy this movie it's
a very well made movie for such a
confusing concept yeah because at the
beginning you're just like how how am i
supposed to follow along when the
movie's playing in backwards how am i
supposed to like how is anything
supposed to be surprising to me and um
he finds a way to keep it interesting
throughout the entire run of the movie
and then the ending kind of just like
slaps you in the face you're like oh oh
[ __ ] i did not see that coming yeah okay
and uh yeah and then i've and then uh
this kind of launched his career and i
feel like this is one of his best works
yeah i agree with that wow thank you
thank you thank you
that's great
welcome to my ted talk good evening
it is i the g-dog az anime
man so the boys aren't with me right now
but it's okay because i'm going to
channel their energy to do this ad read
i love pizza crusts today's episode of
trash taste is sponsored by punishing
grey raven as commander of the grave
raven unit you'll be assembling an elite
team of cybernetically augmented
soldiers leading them into intense
action combat missions and unraveling
the dark truths behind the virus
disasters and guys you're in luck
because this is already out yes the
first version of punishing grave raven
frozen darkness has been released on
august 3rd the new s attacking character
lucia alpha one of the most powerful
characters in the game has just been
released this patch as well and guys i
gotta be honest the art style the action
battle and the gameplay is gonna
surprise you also one of our old enemies
rosetta is gonna be introduced this
update as well and the expert difficulty
levels bring you so much fun fierce
action battles in the activity of frozen
darkness you can unlock a class hero
kamui bastion in our event by card
exchanging for free find out about his
unique skills of tackling the enemy so
if that sounds interesting to you then
you can click the link in the
description to give the game a go today
thank you very much to punishing grave
raven for sponsoring us today back to
the episode i definitely need to watch
kung fu hustle and confessions yeah um
so have you watched scott pilgrim of
course yeah i like scott pilgrim i
really like scott it's a good movie yeah
it's a good movie it's a good movie i
think it's a really good movie um i mean
i'm a huge fan of edgar wright edgar
wright's the other director where i'm
just like whatever you make i'll [ __ ]
watch it edgar wright is like the master
of visual comedy yeah where like he he
manages to cut something in a way or
just like edit something in a way that
just makes it like whoa that i wasn't
expecting out of that but that's
hilarious yeah it's just he's one of the
few people who whatever genre he takes
on he'll put his own spin on the genre
yeah like it's it's so
rare to find someone who you can just
watch a movie not and you can just tell
this edgar wright through the editing
itself because it's such a snappiness
yeah it's just like the unique and the
the snappiness and the like it's very
it's very rhythmic isn't it yeah yeah
yeah
is this your favorite egg right film i
think it is i think mine is still shawn
of the dead because i was debating
putting sean of the dead on hot fuzz i i
like fuzz that's a great hot fuzz is
good i just feel like the first half was
like a little bit boring
um that's why i don't think it's as
strong as uh sean of the dead um and
scott pilgrim i feel like is the most
edgar wright film there is i feel i feel
scott pilgrim couldn't be made by any
other no no that's that's the thing
right i feel sean on the dead sean penn
uh is that his name sean pan yeah sean
penn and uh nick
cannon no i was about to say nick fury
then i was like wait that's that's not
nick nick frost nick
the one that dies in every movie yeah
sean penn is the one that always dies in
every movie
why is there so many shows
sean penn is uh who's sean
who the [ __ ] is that
whatever now we've got a [ __ ] living
imdb page right here
she was she played uh kevin spacey's
wife in house of cards
i haven't seen house i haven't seen him
i've seen house of cards okay but going
back to scorpion the reason i put this
on is because like i do do really really
[ __ ] like sean of the dead um but i
feel like scott pilgrim is just the most
edgar wright movie to exist at the
moment it's him on like his best form
and i feel like it's
this this movie kind of like i feel like
defined a whole generation of nerds
like you you've seen so many people who
just based their entire [ __ ]
personality on this one movie you know
who you are you know who you [ __ ] are
like you meet you me you meet that
person that like you meet one person
like that and like every anime
convention you go to of course yeah
it's um but well i mean i think the
reason why it works so well is because
like again edgar wright's like way of
directing is very like over exaggerated
and like very not rooted in valley and
that works perfectly with scott pilgrim
because scotland was based off a [ __ ]
comic book series all right so i know
i'm a very complicated was it the first
echo right film you watched oh sean of
the show like i literally watched his
movies
i feel like it's out of like the
cornetto trilogy it's like the
like the middle favorite for me it's
like sean of the dead hot fuzz then i
can't remember the third one they made
balls in
world's end that's it also i think hot
fuzz is like that's like where i grew up
those kind of towns yeah oh yeah
oh [ __ ] that's right it's very much like
if you're not like
familiar with british like yeah it's
literally just like they ripped my town
oh i noticed they didn't but that's very
much similar to like yeah i feel like
that was the vibe they were going for
that's why hot fuzz like barely made it
big in the u.s because like you know a
lot of the references just americans i
mean i i feel like sean of the dead and
hot fuzz were both very much cold hits
yeah yeah um because they're very much
ingrained in you know british humor and
british culture you know you you watch
hot fuzz and you probably can get a vibe
of what the place like he grew up in
which is like nothing that happened to
you yeah yeah it's just like not
something you can say for many other
british films even yeah
i mean people when when people think
british films they or british culture
they're like oh it's like harry potter
right
everything's like harry potter over
there
everyone's just whizzing yeah but i
think another thing that's been lost
through time was just how [ __ ]
unpopular this was when this first came
out because now like it's like now it's
just like nerd culture haha mainstream
nerd culture hi i'm uh i'm a nerd guys
i identify as a nerd but i remember when
i first saw this um in theaters i saw
this by myself
in a completely empty theater in
brighton right wow really because nobody
wanted to see this [ __ ] movie
nobody is it a marketing issue huh was
it a marketing issue
maybe maybe the nerds just didn't want
to expose themselves right except for
guys
normally you know it's normally a
marketing issue especially if it's a
good movie
i mean this movie this movie [ __ ]
bombed in the cinemas it was it was only
after definitely definitely cult yeah it
definitely became a cult movie that got
picked up and more people watched as
like nerd culture became more mainstream
but i remember the first time watching
this it blew my [ __ ] mind how good
this was and i couldn't tell anyone
about it because nobody was interested
in watching it like
how did i sell this how did you sell
this to someone yeah like go back go
back 20 years how do you sell this to
someone to like one of your mates or
something this time is really good you
want to watch it again
what's it like what's like tell me i'll
i'll just take you just shut up shut up
and i'll take you don't expect anything
watch the popcorn have a good time is it
like the three it's like the food
[ __ ] off
there's good music space jam you already
mentioned that you grew up with that
yeah
what about matrix though the matrix i
mean do you really feel that strongly
about the matrix honestly as a kid yeah
i did as a kid yeah i i feel like it's
one of those things where i i just care
about it it's like referential like it's
so famous and so referenced yeah but now
i don't really give a [ __ ] about the
matrix yeah i don't really give about
the i don't really give a revolutionary
when it came out yeah it was like whoa
you can do that i was surprised like
that [ __ ] scene where they put the
thing inside of it the stomach gave me
nightmares oh i mean i've already talked
about that yeah
that [ __ ] gave me nightmares i will
say
um i don't think the matrix has aged
very well oh no definitely i've
definitely especially the first one i've
definitely rewatched it and i'm just
like oh god i thought this was really
cool i thought this was like the coolest
thing when it came out because that's
that's why it's kind of [ __ ] it's kind
of [ __ ] it definitely has an age wall no
it definitely has no age but that's
because there's been since the matrix
there's been a million matrix yeah i
just shot better but i mean like i feel
like part of the big reason i got into
anime was because of the matrix as well
because i'm just like i see this and
then this was like my anime taste for a
long time because i thought this was
cool as [ __ ] and i wanted to find more
things like this iconic as [ __ ] yeah
it's iconic as [ __ ] and
i remember i think the first time i saw
this when did this come out in 1999 97 i
think okay i think i was like nine or
ten when i first saw it it's way too
young to be seeing this yeah yeah um but
i remember thinking this was like the
coolest thing which it was it was for
the time right
for the time showing your age there
when he like pulls the red and blue
pillow
yeah which one is he gonna be but by my
my age when i was old enough to be able
to appreciate it it kind of fallen out
oh definitely because it was like what
like 16 so
yeah at that time right there'd already
been a million coins of matrix
by the time it came up for you like you
people are dressed like people in the
matrix are like neck beards with holding
a katana with like a fedora right this
is like you think you if the matrix was
made nowadays it's just like the person
who's just learned the way of the blade
yeah i didn't really watch many like
nerd movies though growing up like i
never what defines a nerd yeah what
defines a nerd movie star wars i've
still yet to watch the original star
wars trilogy really i just lord of the
rings or anything like that i love lord
of the rings okay i mean that's probably
the nerdiest of me i haven't watched
lord of the rings the [ __ ] you have
always lord of the rings wait what's
weird
you haven't much stall no you're sure
okay you're both [ __ ] weird to me
you ever watched star wars you haven't
watched it i feel like you have to watch
lord of the rings i feel like you have
to watch star wars in that sense
you don't have to okay you don't have to
watch one two and three just at least
four five six
yeah i've only watched one two and three
[Music]
i don't count that as watching star wars
i've i've not watched the original
trilogy you have to watch the original
trailer i just don't give a [ __ ] if you
sat through 12 hours of lord of the
rings you can sit through three star
wars i love i used to watch like the
director's cut of lord of the rings
yeah but we used to go to france every
holiday yeah and uh it was a 12-hour
journey
oh like longer than 12 so i was like
great i'll watch the lord of the rings
director cuts back to back in one city
oh my god
i like lord of the rings but that's too
much lord of the rings
the reason i haven't watched lord of the
rings is okay i have watched the first
movie fell asleep thought it was boring
never came back really oh how old were
you
when did when did it come out
a lot of the
the first one fellowship of the ring
came out in like mid-2000s right did it
i think it was yeah wait like 2003 or
something yeah so i remember my cousin
watching it um
holy [ __ ] it's a 20 year old movie so i
think i was about like 13 14 when i
attempted to watch it and i don't know
like how that's like the prime time
though i feel
i this is gonna sound weird from like
coming from the isekai guy
i just i just don't find fantasy or that
interesting what the [ __ ] that's all you
[ __ ] talk about that's all you talk
about yeah okay okay okay okay watch it
now you like fantasy
go back and watch it now yeah anime
fantasy yeah i [ __ ] slept i [ __ ]
[ __ ] with that real life fantasy get the
[ __ ] out of my face oh my god what a
weeb
go watch it actually give it a shot if
it doesn't have a hot anime titties in
an sky world i don't want it basically
i appreciate it is the main character
overpowered no frodo's like afraid i
can't do [ __ ] he just
is so good that's why it's good because
he fights through all of these like
insanely impossible to survive
situations with the power of friendship
bro but every single movie has just
amazing scenes in it dude sam best waifu
i'm just saying right now he's best
wifey dude he supports frodo till from
start to finish what's your favorite
lord of the rings movie joey probably
the third one see that's what i mean you
can say any single any one of those
movies is the best movie and i i i'm
like that's totally fair like every
single movie is great all three movies
are fantastic dude yeah so good
yeah maybe we should watch it together
it's long though it's it's long yeah we
don't have to watch the director's cut
and [ __ ] like we can we can watch the
normal ones which is still like 10 hours
but still
the director's cut can only really be
appreciated after you've loved the first
card yeah because you want the bonus
stuff yeah exactly you need to make sure
you love it first okay i'm speaking
you've begun to watch lord of the rings
i'm sitting you down
no no no no no i don't think you do i
don't feel like starting unnecessary
honestly honestly i'm i'm i'm uh okay
i've pissed off lord of the rings fans
let me piss off star wars say it all
right say
i know the plot to the uh the original
trilogy yeah like darth vader i just
think darth vader looks [ __ ] boring
i've played the lego games so
i know the story so i basically know
star wars guys i know the story and i
just think that like darth maul [ __ ]
badass okay to be fair general grievous
uh
only the coolest [ __ ] yeah
general grievous is the the coolest
[ __ ] uh star wars character i guess
he is to be fair to be fair
[Music]
star wars i'm just gonna say i think
episode one is actually really [ __ ]
good i think it's well obviously because
i prefer the pretty small fight and the
pod racing is like the two greatest
scenes in star wars honestly like
because the reason i prefer the prequels
to defend myself is okay
number one i really don't give a [ __ ]
about star wars i like
it it's fair it's just not something i'm
interested i'm not passionate about star
wars either yeah yeah the lego games are
just banging
they were just great sure and it's just
like i remember watching i've actually
seen the original trilogy a lot of times
because someone's always got it on in
the background someone's always watching
it at some [ __ ] family um family
gathering or something was like playing
at christmas i don't know why but
someone's always watching this i've seen
it so many [ __ ] times and i i kind of
find it like just boring i don't
it's just a very
standard movie with like it's it's it's
just uh
what's original about star wars nowadays
well nowadays it's not because again
like very much like matrix it's just
being copied to [ __ ] it's kind of just
like the matrix to me where it's just it
to me it's just boring now it's just a
very normal standard movie and she's
like yeah
luke goes on the hero's journey and
darth vader is the villain and yadda
yadda yeah that's why that wasn't really
interesting that's why i never like
cared to watch episodes seven eight and
nine because in my mind i'm just like
it's not really like a fantasy to like
i think so yeah
episode seven was the only one where
people were like it was pretty good yeah
but like to me there are so many like
scenes in the in the prequels that just
stand out to me like that [ __ ] jewel
with darth maul and like okay [ __ ]
gin i know everyone holy [ __ ] that is
iconic to this day still is the best
spicy styles and it has the best theme
oh my god the ball theme dude yeah yeah
dolphin was terrifying as well darth
maul was [ __ ] tough [ __ ] darth vader
yeah like like what's what's what's
scary about someone having asthma
i have asthma does that make me [ __ ]
scary no also in the prequels we didn't
get to see anna can kill the kids yeah i
like that part
i like are you kidding me like like the
first time you see like um count dooku
fight yoda holy [ __ ] man that was that
church for me to me that was like by far
the one star wars the only thing that i
mean
the only thing that hurts me about the
the original three episodes is that
jonah is literally in all of them yoda
is literally a puppet people love that
though yeah i know but i said i don't
get that i prefer when he's like you
know has a motion initially yeah yeah no
i i liked him when he was [ __ ] sharp
yeah when he was like flipping in the
air when he brings out the light saber
he starts like doing [ __ ] like
gymnastics and all this [ __ ] i love
samuel jackson bro yeah samuel jackson
like samuel jackson is the only thing
that made the clone wars bearable yeah
yeah yeah when he pulls out the purple
lights and i was like my man let's go
because like the coolest the only thing
i actually gave a [ __ ] about star wars
was the jedi's and what's not in the
[ __ ] like what's hardly in the
original trilogy and like the sequels
it's the jedi's that's what i wanted i
want to see cool jedi's fights i want to
see cool lightsaber fights also all the
best memes come from the prequels yeah
that's just which is like yeah it did
get meme to [ __ ] yeah definitely so yeah
i i'm i'm i'm sticking by my gun i
prefer the star wars prequels come at me
star wars i won't have any dislikes this
clip's gonna happen
i just yeah star wars is kind of boring
you know i mean it's kind of weird
i'm not going to sit here and pretend
like it's the greatest fantasy story
ever but i mean you know it's decent i
mean that's the biggest thing i'm more
passionate about not caring about star
wars and like lord of the rings i've
seen some of like the action scenes
there i'm like i could probably get into
it there's just the battles bro the
battles are [ __ ] happening
helms deep bro got me acting up so good
battles are so good all the
rings yeah we still haven't had battles
as good as lord of the rings it's been
like 20 years and no nothing has come
close dude give me another hour and a
half long fight scene man it's insane
bro that guy literally pitched that and
they were like all right let's do it so
you want the fight scene to be howling
yeah and they [ __ ] did it but they
did it
it's an hour and a half
like battle scene okay and it just
doesn't that doesn't cut away amazing
it's literally an hour and a half
[ __ ] amazing all right i guess you've
sold me i i guess they still build
character and story yeah in the in a
battle without like [ __ ] disbelief
of what's going on is everything it's
like literally they're like in the
middle of [ __ ] they're literally
monologuing as they're fighting because
i actually remember why i stopped
watching lord of the rings
because i was actually watching it with
my cousin
and so they go on this journey and i
kept asking are they there yet
she got so [ __ ] pissed off with me
because i'm just like
it's like because i was just like
they're there yeah when are they going
to get there we're going to get there
like are they close to coming there and
they're like he's like god shut the [ __ ]
up
you also can't watch lord of the rings
with someone who is a gear fan no
because if they you need someone to shut
the [ __ ] up when you're watching god oh
my god that's my paper okay please
please people who love lord of the rings
unfortunately will tell you everything
about lord of the rings throughout every
single moment yeah okay yeah please
don't be that guy who just quotes the
movie as it happens i i literally can't
stand that it is my least favorite thing
and like what's even worse is like not
even when they're quoting it out out
loud when they think they're being
conspicuous about it and they just like
like start mouthing to themselves
no the one i hate more is when they
whisper to themselves yeah right before
it happens yeah yeah yeah when they're
like i get it you've seen this movie
seventeen thousand times shut the [ __ ]
up
when people like oh this part's good
it's like well i'll i'll decide that
don't tell me the card's good i'm about
to [ __ ] watch it i'll decide if this
part is good yeah don't be that guy
please
or that part i mean i mean i i've like i
you know you always have that part where
you show someone a movie you really like
but i try to be as subtle about it as i
can because like in my mind i'm like
this good this good part's coming up and
like try to like
see on the corner of my eye if they're
watching it like if if if i was
invisible i'd be like full on l mode you
know like that scene from definitely
just like
don't look at me like that it's [ __ ]
crazy that's that's the other pet peeve
i have when i'm showing a movie to a
friend or whoever and and in my head i'm
like oh this next scene they're gonna
love and i look over and they're just
out on their oh god
don't be that guy yeah don't be like
etiquette come on movie etiquette but
anyway that's my three by three these
are not my favorite film or some of
these i [ __ ] with um still some of these
are just there because
well i mean they're a child of movies
they're my childhood movies that's what
3x3 is all about this episode is
sponsored by us trash taste we have mugs
now
look at this
on a scale of one to ten how much do you
want to drink tea out of this market ten
out of ten it comes with its own lid oh
my god the lid comes off not only is it
just a collector's item i mean look at
this thing this would look amazing on
your shelf it's also highly practical
and it's a good sized mug look at this
this is so good i've already been
drinking coffee this is a used market
i'm sorry for promoting
my [ __ ] gone [ __ ] me how many times
thank god that it's ceramic and really
easy to clean up i know how many times
did you miss your mouth
you've you've seen how i sipped joey
look look
now you can reenact that meme or just
about like sips disgustingly you can get
your own trash taste mug oh my god it's
beautiful it's a beautiful material
29.99 plus shipping and uh i think we're
it's limited right yeah yeah yeah
so get them while they lost yeah and the
first thousand people who order one of
these mugs will get a personal letter
from us
a little little trash taste logo on the
back oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah sorry i
can't show you because i've literally
still got coffee in here guys you can
only pre-order these for the next three
weeks so if you want your very own trash
taste bug this is the only chance to get
it and it's for the next three weeks and
once they're gone we're not bringing
them back so you can pre-order them
right now go down to trashtastemugs.com
links down in the description below and
support the boys and get yourself your
very own trash taste mug so you can
watch trash taste and drink your trash
taste mug with us while we drink
you really feel like you're part of the
boys like this by going to
trashtasmarks.com don't be a peasant
drink like a king with trash
get four trash taste mugs for the whole
family for the set only mouth breathers
don't drink out of trash taste milks
does your mug have a have a lid
i don't think so this one has a leg this
one has a lid and it's a fantastic lid
fire trash taste mag what are you doing
link's in the description back to the
episode all right joey who is next oh
should i do it because yeah yeah yeah
all right who's next
me or connor
joey joey okay i'm always last right
yeah you are why is that
all right well hopefully mine won't be
too pretentious
[Laughter]
okay okay is mine pretentious i know
first i saw apocalypse now and i'm just
like did you just go through the imdb
top 250. okay okay so i'll go through
them so from top left to bottom right we
have king speech
bruce almighty apocalypse now pulp
fiction goodfellas uh austin powell's
gold member gladiator and kamera
tomorrow
okay i've seen every english speaking
movie this one i had a feeling you'd put
two japanese japanese
what are these nihongo movies i say that
as i put one on youtube
um
yeah so which ones have you guys seen
and not seen uh
all of these except for poc i don't
think i've seen apocalypse now oh you've
never seen apocalypse now i haven't seen
apocalypse
the two japanese films okay so like as i
was saying earlier like i always have
that like top three movies in case
anyone in like a panel always asks yeah
and my top three that i always bring up
is apocalypse now pulp fiction and
goodfellas
i mean those are all [ __ ] bangers
obviously i mean this isn't this top top
uh 10 imdb films
i feel like goodfellas and pulp fiction
are definitely like oh yeah good fellas
and pulp fiction are definitely up there
i've never wait no i haven't watched
goodfellas oh you've never seen
goodfellas i've never watched a
godfather or goodfellas oh really yeah
have you not you know it you know how
you said like sometimes you just save a
movie that you just know you're gonna
love
you know i don't need to watch it right
now but i know i will and i know i'll
enjoy it yeah i mean like i feel like if
we're going through like that imdb thing
right like most people are like oh yeah
godfather like the godfather trilogy
yeah that's definitely one of those and
it's like the godfather trilogy is good
and like oh i like a lot of mods
scorsese films but i think out of all of
them goodfellas it's a tie for me
between goodfellas and casino
yeah
i feel like cena is so underrated yeah
casino feels very underrated man
scorsese film but i put good fellas
there because it was like it's the
classic it's the classic it's it's it
was the first like
score safe is what i'm seeing yeah
it's it was the first monster scorsese
like gangster film i ever watched yeah
yeah um and then like you know and then
obviously i went back after that and was
like oh watch godfather and taxi driver
and like all those i think the thing
about godfather is that i i obviously
recognize it as a good movie but there's
there's there's a difference between me
being like oh this is a really good
movie too this is a movie that i really
personally enjoy and for me godfather is
like something that i could recognize
was really good it was just a bit slow
sometimes
i feel like martin's called lazy
gangster films it's just godfather but
just a bit more condensed a bit more a
bit more snappy you know i mean i mean
yeah like uh martin scorsese did the do
you departed yeah they did the party
that's probably one of my favorite
that's a fantastic [ __ ] i mean again
everything he's made like wolf of wall
street as well was fantastic yeah
martial says he's just amazing he's just
a great
he's just a really really good filmmaker
yeah consistent raging ball as well was
another one oh yeah yeah yeah basically
every movie you can think of that has
robert de niro in it it's probably a
scorsese film honestly they're like
robert de niro and joe pesci is just
like one of the best duos like you you
see them together and you know it's
going to be a banger film
the part that killed me though was like
i remember because i was i was telling
aki about this good good movie because
she'd never seen her before and she was
like who's in it and i was like oh uh
you know robert de niro and like joe
passion is like yeah i know and then i
was like oh and ray leota's in it as
well and she's like oh yeah i know that
guy from b-movie
[Laughter]
how does she know that because she loves
b-movie and i'm like you're dead to me
oh that poor man that's it ray leona's
legacy is literally goodfellas and
b-movie
because i did ask i can't think of
another ray leona movie i'm sure he's
been in a bunch of other movies i know
i've seen him in other things i just
can't think of it at the top of my head
but i mean like i don't really have to
explain pulp fiction it's like one of
the most like i am normie cult classic
[ __ ]
place i like cinema
it's it's it's like i i swear to god it
was like either perfect or if if you
want to look like you have a personality
in university you put a quentin
tarantino poster on your wall right yeah
it's either a pulp fiction poster or a
reservoir yeah yeah yeah
i put a tarantino film on my list so i
guess we can debate it when we get to
that
which one is the truth i mean i've seen
everything by tarantino he's like one of
my favorite directors but i still think
to this day pulp fiction is
in my personal opinion it's my favorite
it's really close between pulp fiction
and reservoir i i still put reservoir
dogs i'll save money
we will say we'll save we'll save that
we'll save the quantity uh and then
apocalypse now is my favorite war film
okay so what's the apocalypse what's it
even about apocalypse now is based on
the vietnam war yeah that's all i know
about it like basically the uh it's it's
told from the american side where like
american troops are told so uh
martin sheen is the main character
and he is like set on a mission to go
and pick up a soldier from like he's
like he's like a vet who's the director
from the vin uh francis ford coppola
it's the same person who made godfather
oh yeah so francois koppler like this is
like one of his most famous films i
think did you know francis ford coupler
is actually the uncle to nicholas cage
random fact that i found out at the end
of the day okay but anyway so basically
it's said where like martin sheen's
character's team has to go into the
vietnam forest to go and look for this
like vet who holds a lot of information
about the vietnam war yeah basically
he's kind of gone insane and is living
in the vietnam war because it's marlon
brando
basically it's it's uh yeah so marlon
brando's character is this like viet
like soldier vet who like holds a lot of
information and like he needs to be
brought back to the us army basically
martin sheen's character goes in tries
to fight off all the the viet cong and
you know tries to get him back basically
but as
manchin's character is going through all
of these like life and death situations
stuff like that he too also slowly
starts to lose his mind and then
eventually and then you know that poster
there's pretty much [ __ ] awesome
poster yeah pretty much sums up like
that scene where he like comes out of
the pool as there's like fighting
happening is one of the coolest [ __ ]
scenes in cinema i'm gonna watch that
now that sounds cool like marlon brando
is like fantastic is it a thinking movie
i don't know what do i have to think
during this movie well okay so
apocalypse now
has like a a director's cut called
apocalypse now redux which is like three
and a half hours long because how long
is the original three hours oh yeah so
it's all along okay okay because here's
the thing about apocalypse now because
everything you described i already kind
of knew about because i knew like the
basic plot description and everything
like that yeah what makes it good
okay so in my opinion what makes it
really good is just the fact well first
of all it's like the music choice in
that movie is [ __ ] brilliant it's
like everything i [ __ ] love like in
my opinion apocalypse now still has one
of the greatest openings i've seen like
any movie very iconic yeah um but i
don't know it's also just like again
it's like it takes that like kind of war
element and weirdly enough it's a
vietnam war film that doesn't really
have a whole lot of fighting yeah like
really the most amount of like fighting
between the us army and vietnam really
happens in like the first like maybe 20
minutes right and then the rest of the
movie is literally just you're inside
the mind of manchin's character as he's
like
slowly venturing closer and closer to
his target and he's slowly like losing
his mind as a result of war and it's
like a very like i don't know it's like
a really weird like psychological twist
on a war movie that you don't really
like because when you think of war movie
right you think of like saving private
ryan whereas like yeah there's obviously
a lot of like you know
soldiers getting [ __ ] up in the war
scenes right but like there's also a lot
of like fighting scenes
right like gunfighting scenes or
whatever the [ __ ] it is whereas
apocalypse now doesn't really have a
whole lot of that it's like it's almost
like a psychological horror set during
the vietnam war okay and i think that's
what personally that's what makes it
really interesting to me yeah because
it's cool because the thing is i think i
know more about apocalypse now than the
actual than actually seeing the movie
itself yeah yeah because i i know like i
think this has like a really interesting
story behind how it was made yeah uh
because like i i think uh
the director himself i think almost went
bankrupt making this movie or something
like that yeah uh because he had to like
convince the studio that he owned or
something to like lend him the money to
make this movie and he was out there for
like months and months shooting this
movie it almost wasn't made and i think
like marlon brando just refused to read
the script yeah
refused to remember his lines yeah yeah
yeah he's been notorious for that though
yeah he isn't here but this was the
first movie where he started to become
like this and then the godfather i think
happened after apocalypse now which like
then or was it the other way around i
think it was the other way it might have
been the other way around yeah basically
yeah marlon brando doesn't appear in
this movie until maybe about two and a
half hours yeah i thought i think like
most of his lines are just like
ad-libbed because he just refused to
remember his line so i'm just like how
does that work how does that look like
i've ever seen any any of the movies
that he's in but i know that he's like
notorious for being awful to work with
yeah yeah i mean you know like during
his prime obviously he was a fantastic
and you know he's still a fantastic
actor in this movie as well but it's
like it's very clear that he's not like
at his peak but i feel like martin
sheen's performance in this movie is
just so goddamn good yeah that like he
does such an amazing job of like
really like progressively showing
someone going inside yeah yeah yeah i
don't know it's funny might be a
fantastic movie i remember i think it
was on joe rogan i think um
uh
no no no no um robert downey jr was
talking about sometimes he didn't
remember lines yeah like i think when he
did
which i think sherlock he remembered all
his lines for but other movies he was
like just put put an earpiece in just
feeding their lives well honestly like
especially when he's like iron man he's
just acting robert downey jr
he was saying you know some films don't
require me to get that deep into the
character so there's no point in
spending all this time learning the
lines but like i think for like sherlock
it was like quite difficult some of the
lines in the way that he was doing it so
he wanted to learn it yeah he's like
yeah it depends on the movie but the way
he's he made it sound made it seem like
oh that makes sense then when you hear
about like the third party accounts of
marlon brando yeah this sounds like
[ __ ] hell yeah right and i bet like
you know because there's a lot of big
actors in this name like um harrison
ford's in this movie as well yeah just
before he's angry at everything this is
before he's angry
yeah but like i don't know just really
really good movie in my opinion um
king's speech all right okay i was
surprised that that came out of nowhere
i never i've never heard jerry mentioned
this film ever okay to be fair this is
probably the most recent film i watched
that really made like a massive impact
on me because like because he's obsessed
with the royal family no it's because
aoki is obsessed with biopics
so before i met archaea i'd never really
cared to watch a lot of like biopics
biopics are like movies based off real
people's lives so essentially um and so
i watched a shitload of biopics with aki
so like imitation game was another one i
was thinking about
um good movie theory of everything is
another great movie but i don't know
something about king speech i mean
firstly i [ __ ] love jeffrey rush yeah
he's like one of my favorite actors like
everything that he had and he's done
such a [ __ ] good job in this movie as
well and i don't know it's just like
it's a really simple movie but it's just
the acting in this is just so goddamn
believable yeah it's just so good
i've never actually watched it but i
also um when i was
growing up my best mate for like my
whole childhood had like a really bad
stutter yeah so i always had to order
from at things and everything yeah yeah
and uh yeah i don't know this movie came
out and i think it was a big deal yeah
i mean i think it won best picture at
the oscars yeah it did yeah
i mean like i i the reason i knew a lot
about stuttering because again my best
mate had it and he had to go to a bunch
of like uh therapy and stuff to try and
get it because he was like you know like
even like at like 16 17 18 yeah couldn't
like you know order at places right
right and so i i just got used to doing
it yeah um
and then yeah it was really interesting
because i think in the movie they kind
of like gloss over it but like in real
life the way that you like get like you
can solve it there's like with so many
different methods yeah my mate had to
wear like uh a belt
like a big belt around his chest to make
his breathing different oh wow
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean the movie
actually does go through like all the
actual steps that oh okay
that the king actually had to go through
and stuff like that and
yeah it's really interesting as well and
it's just cool to think that like a lot
of this stuff actually happened yeah
and at the end like king
george was his name i can't remember i
don't know
what whatever the king's name was like
actually got over a stutter in real life
as a result of this dude who just you
know solved it and i don't know it's
just like it's very like
because you like meticulously watched
through like every single step and every
failure of the game trying to get over a
starter yeah it's just like the ending
speech is just really powerful and like
really rewarding being like [ __ ] yeah
dude you nailed that [ __ ]
my man let's go i mean i saw it a while
ago and i just remember it was it was a
good movie um
i think this movie got me into biopics
oh okay yeah okay like after i was like
okay you know what i thinks might be
kind of cool i'm glad you guys didn't
put any like documentaries or anything i
was like we have to say that for another
time oh yeah we'll save that from yeah
we'll say that for another time
connor would do like a [ __ ] 10 bites
um and then obviously bruce almighty
were talking about like
who hasn't seen bruce i mean it's it's
like morgan freeman is god i still think
of morgan freeman as god morgan just
because of bruce almighty yeah it's like
the most 2000s film ever yeah it is like
2000
might come out 90s but yeah i think this
is like this encapsulates the feeling of
the 2000s exactly like everyone in it is
amazing it's still funny to this day
yeah basically
like because of this movie if i die and
i don't see morgan freeman at the pearly
gates i'll just want to refund on life
like take me to hell
i explicitly died with the expectation
that morgan freeman
um and then what's another obvious one i
mean austin powell's gold members before
you get to these ones yeah explain
explain the japanese films the japanese
okay explain the hong kong wait which
one do you want to hear about the first
one the top one the top one okay so
darshan
so this was during a time this was
during like a very uh
i guess pretentious period of my high
school life where i was like i want to
watch a lot of really old films okay so
darshan is one uh it's done by this guy
called akira kurosawa oh it's an akira
creation
film who's known as one of the greatest
film directors hello i'm a film buff
mention one name hello i'm a filmmaker
i'm a pretentious film boss so i sat
down and watched every akira kurosawa
film and
is one of them and it's essentially it's
really hard to kind of explain but
basically i think this movie was made in
like
1950 i think yeah yeah black and white
film but basically it revolves around
this like one murder case that happens
in like edo period japan and it's and
the same uh i guess murder is told from
different perspectives and different
characters so like it kind of plays
around i don't know if it was the first
movie to ever do but it kind of plays
around with the whole like unreliable
narrator like logic that a lot of movies
use now and it's just like
i don't know the cinematography in it is
like it's hard to believe this movie was
made 70 years ago yeah i mean that's why
every [ __ ] big director in their big
film buff still says his name
is your favorite director's favorite
director yeah yeah yeah yeah basically
yeah and then like i i feel that darshan
was one of those movies that like took
everything that akira curacao was like
really good at in terms of filmmaking
yeah just like crushed it into like an
hour 30 minutes like solid movie and
like mifune toshiro is like the guy in
the poster who's in like basically every
[ __ ] akira kurosawa movie but like
he's one of my favorite japanese actors
just because like i don't know
he he kind of you know there's that like
weird stigma of japanese acting where
it's like way over the top and like
really unrealistic yeah we've talked
about it which we talked about like
mifune toshiro in my opinion like kind
of took that and almost made it his own
yeah cause like every mufune toshiro
character is like so over exaggerated in
terms of like emotion and like movement
and stuff like that like i'd be very
surprised if he didn't do like theater
training yeah and [ __ ] like that but
like i don't know it's over exaggerated
but it's still like
believable if that makes sense okay and
it's like it becomes really like kind of
i don't know what the right word for it
is i know i sound very pretentious right
now but
but it's a real go ahead
but like in my opinion
like there's lots of really good
accuracy movies yeah i think the only
one i've seen is seven samurai seven
samurais it was like the classic yeah
that's that's the one where that like
fight scene goes on for so goddamn long
that might be the i mean there's a lot
of like that was a really weird sure
there's a lot of fight scenes
the other the other seven samurai did
they have a remake
there was a western arena yeah there was
a western remake also the magnificent
seven is the western version of that
film uh which is also a classic i think
maybe i'll watch what are they called 13
assassins that's a remake right of uh
that's
i don't know actually
i think that's the first story is it
yeah yeah is that a really really long
fight in seven sam right uh i don't know
about seven samurai but like the one
that i can think of as a really long
fight is probably iran
i don't know
you've probably seen seven samurai if
you've gone through if you went through
the phrase of going through like the
imdb top you've probably seen it you've
probably seen about five because like
i've watched a movie called seven
samurai that was in black and white and
there was a there was a fight scene yeah
that was like two hours long and i was
just like sitting there like what is
when is it gonna end i don't know about
i don't think seven samurai was even two
hours long yeah no it was it was it was
like three and a half hours
yeah is there a long fight scene in
seven sounds
that was just a very long movie
i mean it's probably the scene it's
probably the film you're thinking i want
to know if i've watched it you've
probably seen it it's it's it's a
classic like it's definitely on the imdb
like there's probably about five
accuracy films if you go through the
imdb it's actually only one it's only
seven samurai i was about to say
um because that's the only one here
that's on the imdb top 250. so that's
the only one that most people have only
seen probably even though he has like
such a wealth of work yeah i mean ron
was i think his first color film and
that was also [ __ ] fantastic i think
i think the stigma is that a lot of
akira kurosawa films are like based
around like samurai and [ __ ] like that
yeah when like later on in his career he
did a lot of like kind of
rooted more in like modern day stuff
there's there's another film that i
thought about putting up there called
ikiru which means to live yeah and it's
essentially this like kind of
coming-of-age story of this old man who
realizes that he's like about to die and
basically like you know the movie the
bucket list with [ __ ] yeah like
morgan jackman jack nicholson i feel
that completely ripped off of the cure
because it's it's almost like because
the concept is exactly the same it's
like an old guy wanting to like kind of
rediscover his life and like really like
give meaning to his life on his deathbed
okay but like told him like a really
like cool artistic acura kurosawa esque
right um
yeah i don't know yeah i mean he he's a
legend for reading oh he's allegedly in
the film industry if you're a movie buff
please watch akira kurosawa what's this
i've never okay kameron
is
yeah so basically it's this movie have
you seen it yeah
it's okay i was not expecting anything
out of this movie so i actually watched
this film when did it come up
it very it's quite quite recently it's
like a couple years ago yeah so i
thought it was just gonna be like okay
so the reason why i think this movie is
genius is the way that it was marketed
so the way that it's marketed you look
at this poster and you think oh it's a
zombie film yeah like a b grade zombie
film kind of thing okay it's completely
not it basically takes the zombie film
thing and turns it super [ __ ] meta so
basically what it is it's like i don't
want to give too much away but basically
the movie opens with this
15-20 minute one cut zombie film okay
like there's no cuts in it whatsoever
and then you think oh the credits roll
and that's it but then what happens is
it goes back and it shows you how that
one cut movie is made but told in a
fictional way
it's really difficult it's really
[ __ ] meta it's basically that sounds
cool it's basically a movie
on and there's like all sorts of like
weird like it's actually a comedy
there's also like there's all these like
weird comedic shenanigans that happen
behind the scenes of them shooting that
one-shot 20-minute zombie film yeah so
the movie is about the making of that
movie
that honestly sounds like it's right up
my alley yeah and it's i think you'd
you'd like that i'm just like this is
this that's a goddamn
i'll make a [ __ ] video on this i was
i was not expecting this movie to be
good at all but it was one it's really
really funny and two again like the
whole meta aesthetic of it i was like
whoa i've never and what it gets even
more meta because during the credit
scenes then there's a behind-the-scenes
camera of that camera okay so it's like
a movie within a movie within a movie
and it's like i love it i just love like
the whole meta aesthetic of it but like
i put this on there because like for one
i barely know anyone who's seen it i've
never even heard of it yeah you'd like
yeah i guess people will know yeah the
english title is uh one cut of the dead
one of the dead yeah that sounds so
cliche
but that's exactly it right like it
plays to the strengths of zombie film
cliches and just completely flips it on
its head and just turns it into like
this wacky slapstick comedy
yeah and it's really really cool it
sounds like an episode of harahi or
something right yeah honestly
yeah yeah i mean i feel like the last
zombie movie that i watched that i
really [ __ ] enjoyed was trained to
busan oh that's good
fantastic movie so good and like i i
can't explain why it's really good
because it's just like a very like it
it has like the same beats as just a
standard zombie movie but it's just just
just a really good movie it's a solid
movie this is a solid movie even though
even if like you think you're bored of
the zombie genre
like i think i am somebody yeah because
i thought okay if you're bored of the
zombie genre you need to watch that and
then i gotta watch twenty percent
they're gonna watch other [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
no but like one cut of the dead it was
that was the time yeah one cut of the
day like yeah like i feel if there's any
movie i can recommend on my three by
three it's probably that one just
because it's like it comes like both put
it in the bottom right as well like the
bottom left sorry like it completely
destroys what you think about movies
yeah in a way that's like really fun and
also like just again it's just meta as
[ __ ] if you want that whole meta thing
like you'd love that yeah okay um and
then i put gladiator on there just
because i probably would have put
gladiator too it's a good film
uh yeah it's just good it's just very
it's just good yeah just like there's no
complaint like i don't have any like
special memories with the movie i just i
just think it's really good clean story
just clean that's i like history
it's not it's not even history right i
like tournament arcs
yes that's basically it right radiator
is just a tournament russell crow he's
funny yeah
is a great actor i just realized yeah
this is basically just a [ __ ] shonen
anime yeah set in rome and it's just
condensed down into a movie dude
tournament arc revenge story yeah it's
everything i want russell crowe it's
everything i want yeah and i feel like
it's this and i i was like really close
to putting 300 on mine oh yeah because i
think i like 300. i feel like gladiator
is the better film but i think 300 made
a more of an impression 300 is the more
entertaining variety yeah yeah yeah
before before like zack snyder thought
like before zack snyder thought i could
put slo-mo in everything
what if what if i just do it use it for
everything like i remember 300 is so
good not gonna lie man the slow motion
fight scenes in 300 still [ __ ]
slapped to this day i i feel i i still
think it's zack snyder's best feeling i
was 100 agree like he just he just
peaked with that and he was just like
how do i recapture this
how do i same thing with all my other
films it's such a fun film it is a good
film it's such a quotable just fun like
bloody gory film such a cool story too
yeah it's just it's just like facebook
yeah it's [ __ ] awesome
as much as this one yeah
i mean somewhat yeah you cannot like
watch 300 and not just come out just
hyped as [ __ ]
punch someone the funniest thing about
300 in my opinion is just how they made
xerxes into this like nine foot tall
like brick [ __ ] house when i think in
real life xerxes was like four feet tall
like he was actually a [ __ ] never like
zacks i was like no no let's let's get
the biggest chad in the movie film
industry and just make him play cersei
because i i think have you been have you
been in a like movie theater where
they've literally just gasped
yes yeah because like 300 is the only
experience i've had in a movie theater
where like the whole [ __ ] movie
theater just gasped
um and that was the scene that was like
the very final scene where he throws the
spear oh yeah
that was such a good scene yeah
god that's such a god i want to watch
300 again
it's such a good film you can't not be
happy watching that's just so [ __ ]
such a quotable movie i mean like all of
these films like there's there's at
least one quote i can easily one or two
quotes
yeah let's get into this austin powell's
why
it's gold member what's up with that i
don't know i think it's the best austin
powers movie i don't really like austin
powell you know like austin powers
i watched i re-watched gold member again
just because like one of my friends came
over to my house and was like
i feel like watching gold member and i
was like and i was like i haven't seen
that movie in like 10 years but let's
let's do is that movie still funny now i
feel like it's not funny i think it's
still funny do you think it's funny
anymore i didn't find it funny when it
first came out i'll be honest yeah yeah
i don't know it's uh
it's again it's like that whole like
it's it's the meta thing right it's like
the fact that austin powers as a
character is it's just like james bond
right yeah it's just so aware of what he
is that yeah it's it's the potty humor
poo poo pee pee humor right
it really is it kind of
i i like that humor i don't know why i
didn't like this movie like uh the
golden i've seen uh sorry the austin
power series i think i've seen all of
them and i just thought like yeah that's
all right it's i don't know it's like
for me it's just like comfort food to
just go back to
it's just like it's either that or bruce
almighty in terms of comedy films right
i'm like yeah this is still funny i mean
i i think it's just like the peepee hoop
yeah i feel like
it was a bit bit too in your face yeah
when i think of austin powers i just
feel like i i like recall and discuss
bit i think you know what it is there's
so many gross scenes in that film
you know what it is about gold member in
particular i think it's like the same
concept as like when you see like you
know a troll face comic
on twitter right where it's like it's so
not funny that it's just funny again
it's just ancient music
the second one this is the third one
third one this is one
bastard yeah this is the last one oh
gosh yeah
and like gold member is also played by
uh mike myers where he's like the
[ __ ] dutch guys like i love gold like
that characters like it's so dumb that
it's like it's funny i just i just feel
like i put it in like the same category
as scary movie and do you remember scary
movie see i didn't find scary movies
funny at all i didn't find it funny at
all yeah and it's it's the 16 year old
me love scary movie yeah and then when i
watched it again i was like oh
it's it's the same kind of like
this is a parody kind of humor and i
just like i
i never found that too funny i mean i i
love pee pee poo poo humor jokes but it
was just a bit
too in your face right right yeah i
don't know yeah maybe i i i swear i
probably got a few laughs out of it here
and there but i don't know maybe i don't
know why i think i'm kind of just like
numb to comedy movies now just because
like the past five years of comedy
movies have just all been really [ __ ]
mediocre in mind yeah yeah
many many good comedy like i'm trying to
think of like the last good comedy movie
and like i genuinely four year old
virgin i genuinely think it might be
cold
like i
that was like nearly as fun pretty sure
superbad came off of this yeah right as
a white guy i'm obliged to say step
brothers even though i don't really feel
that way
since we're all doing hot takes on
movies i don't think i don't think i've
ever laughed at a well-feral movie no i
mean there isn't a single will for a lot
i don't think well i don't actually
think stepbrothers is freaking out
there's one scene in step brothers that
i was like
what if there's like 15
like filmography to to see if to see if
i actually because like step brothers
was like okay i thought blazer glory was
not funny at all
they were just like they were the most
six to seven out of ten films yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah what's his most
okay
man i don't know anchorman is just like
just driven to the [ __ ] ground now i
don't know i don't know if that's just
like had the borah
is pretty good i like alf the alpha's
overrate as [ __ ] i think i think else
the the thing that i don't understand
about elf is that like
like it gained like a cult classic
following after like all this time of
being ignored i like talladega night
silence
yeah i'm just looking at this and i'm
just like it's okay everything's
everything's okay yeah like anchorman i
feel like i watched anchorman past when
like it's already it was already memes
to death
um and i feel like the best part of hank
man was steve carell oh yeah
uh
a lot of late night shows listed as
filmography i don't know
um yeah i guess i just don't find will
ferrell that funny i guess
movie's pretty good he's in that what
lego movie oh i like it uh i like i
don't know oh no no no 21 jump street
that was the last great comedy movie
yeah
oh come on come on kill mom come on see
i didn't watch it oh okay
that's really good that was the last
great comedy game what's the original 21
jump street
no the new one's really good yeah yeah
the one with uh what's his face ice cube
and uh
no no the one we saw
like the really really old one with um
oh [ __ ] what's the 21 jump street i
might
[Music]
oh yeah but like i think jonah hill i
prefer jonah hill in like the more
serious movies though jenna hill's so
good now like it's like okay as much as
i love jim carrey bruce almighty like
all the jim carrey like classic comedy
like mask and yeah ranch and all that
i [ __ ] love jim carrey in all the
series yeah seriously like the other one
i was thinking like i'll put bro mighty
there just because it's like the comedy
movie i can go back to it's like classic
but like if i didn't put a bruce on my
didn't put bruce almighty or any jim
carrey comedy i would have put uh you
know the number 23 oh yeah yeah yeah
that's like really like kind of neo noir
like the most serious you like that one
i kind of liked it
i kind of liked it it's like that one or
like eternal sunshine in the spotlight
then another one i saw was truman show
is my favorite jim carrey movie german
show was such a [ __ ] yeah german show
was good yeah yeah i don't know
something about the number 23 was like
it was so
[ __ ] edgy that it just became
entertaining again you know what i mean
we're like
it's like it's like a point of ageiness
where it's like it just comes back
around wasn't that like destroyed by
critics for like it was just pretentious
yeah yeah i mean
wow
have you seen my 3x3 it's pretentious as
[ __ ]
joey's like ah yes i don't understand
perfect i think the fact that i put in
the kira kurosawa film goes to show that
i'm pretty i'm a pretty [ __ ]
pretentious movie creator
wow what do you guys think of while
we're on the topic of comedy movies uh
seth rogen films how do we feel about
that kind of the same same thing i feel
about willful movies
i'm just like expressed he's okay he's
like ha ha he smells weird
i feel like
i feel like if it's not like purely just
seth rogen being a stoner then it's a
pretty funny film i like seth rogen as a
person yeah you know
i like like the stoner actor seth rogen
but like seth rogen in films i'm just
kind of just like i like his movies you
just turn your brain off and uh it's an
easy movie you know you know yeah
sometimes it's just hard movies to watch
i can't even think of like sometimes you
just want movies
our films are not the kind of thing i
can just put on oh no no no of course
it's like some he you know you always
get just a film you can watch yeah
you wanna you want to know how [ __ ]
pretentious i am as a former critic
instead of gold member i was going to
put 2001 a space in my god
i would have actually i would have
actually been like actually [ __ ] off
yeah i actually get the [ __ ] out sorry
who are you trying to please joey
i'm trying to please myself all right
i'm surprised one thing i'm surprised
that's not on here yeah is uh
trainspotting because you've talked
about that a bunch [ __ ] you know what i
completely forgot about it
actually yeah can we can we get rid of
gold member and put train sporting no no
no no
someone criticized me because they said
when someone they asked me what my
favorite video game or whatever was and
i said different from what i put on my
three i think we make off three by
threes in like 10 minutes this is not
like the end all of our actual exactly
exactly which try to make it interesting
yeah yeah they're fine
i'm thinking oh i've really enjoyed this
is the end by uh a seth rogen film oh
what yeah and uh what is uh 50 50 was
really good oh 50 50 was great i haven't
seen any of these
the ones where like the joke isn't just
him being a stoner right
and that's why is that even possible
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah wow all right
okay yeah he does because i think i
think with seth rogen like i watched one
film with seth rogen in it and i was
like was it pineapple express
it might have been that's and i was like
and i was like i
percent understand this actor in this
character she's probably like that in
every other movie yeah yeah i don't know
yeah
oh my god [ __ ] can i talk about
transporting okay okay sorry sorry sorry
it's so good
okay have you guys seen it
i have not you haven't seen it okay so
trainspotting is this like oh god how do
you how the [ __ ] to explain train
sporting i know that it's not about
spotting trains it is not about spotting
trees so the term train spotting comes
from heroin addicts where they try to uh
inject the heroin into their veins so
they have to spot the veins and that is
referred to as train spotting
yeah so basically it's a it's a drug
film uh set in scotland
uh played uh mainly by euro mcgregor
yeah who is in his natural habitat he's
in his natural uh accent so you know
it's going to be good uh very very young
ewan mcgregor yeah i think this is
before star wars i think i think the one
scene i remember from train spotting
apart from the baby scene yeah uh
was just toilet scene yeah just you
mcgregor emerges from the toilet yeah
i've heard about this yeah i've heard of
the scenes in trains yeah so very famous
scene is where your mcgregor needs to go
you know do a hit and he's at a pub and
he goes into the closest no no that's
right no he uh he gets the runs i think
from something yeah and he runs into a
pub and goes into the probably the most
disgusting looking toilet imaginable
yeah like it's it's like it's actually
foul and he drops his drugs into the
toilet oh and because he's a desperate
junkie and he took a shot beforehand he
starts hallucinating as he reaches into
the toilet and just goes into the toilet
and starts swimming into the inside the
toilet emerges out of the toilet with
the drugs oh my god it's a very very
bizarre movie but
i uh
i showed trainspotting to aki right and
she was she stopped it after five
minutes and she's like can we put
subtitles on because i can't understand
what the [ __ ] they're saying
to be fair
it's a very heavy scottish accent like
there are some scenes where even i'm
like oh i didn't quite catch what he
just [ __ ] said there so like
americans this is what i'm saying
probably best to put subtitles being
from the uk is like your english level
is op yeah i understand any any form of
the only reason why the only reason why
i understand train sporting is because i
like watched it like over 10 times
i just remember what they say but uh
yeah i don't know it's just like it's
very brutal film but also it's like
again like the music choices like yeah
if with mute with movies if it's got a
great music choice i'm all for it yeah
same with my anime right if the ost is
good it's a great movie i'd say if
there's like two like drug like films
kind of like what how do i how do i
describe this
is that a category
yeah drug movie drug movie like because
like i don't really know how to describe
train spotting it's just a movie about a
bunch of characters and that's sold on
it to be fair i like how their lives
revolve around drugs and like
trainspotting is one of them and the
other one is requiem for a dream yeah
which is not a film i think like people
should watch to enjoy but i think people
should just watch it at least once yeah
like realize wow i just just never want
to try heroin you know i just that's
that's just a bad thing well i mean
train sporting was definitely one where
i was like oh never touching that [ __ ]
yeah in my life [ __ ] that [ __ ] that
you know i was 50 50 but uh
if you ever have a friend who's like
maybe i might try heroin just show them
train spawn they'll probably be like
nope never drink him for a dream or
recreate for a dream i think i just got
full on [ __ ] depression for a week
after watching that film i mean
trainspotting is definitely another film
that is not watched for entertainment
yeah yeah probably more entertaining
than recording for a dream i i would
like to say like tradespotting isn't a
happy movie but it's like less bleak
than wrecking for a dream
there's a lot there's a lot of great
scenes and it's like i don't know just
again the acting's really good and it's
just very it's a very raw film yeah
requiem for a dream just sounds like
something you'd give an oscar to based
on the title
to be fair there's some great [ __ ]
scenes
like [ __ ] that's awesome yeah the thing
i can say about rec room for a dream is
that it's just
so [ __ ] powerful movie and it's like
it's makes you feel emotions that it's
not pleasant feeling yeah but it's
[ __ ] powerful [ __ ] man speaking of
powerful should we uh get onto my list
go on
is it powerful
it's going to be powerful i actually did
put no country for old men oh wow
what's interesting is off camera this is
mine
yeah yes this one off camera uh she was
like oh yeah i wouldn't put her no
control honestly i was so close to
putting some of these on mine i know you
were gonna put that oh okay okay because
i was like i was like maybe someone else
is gonna put it man but that was so
close to coming on my way this is a
powerful list i think gentlemen i think
you know what
the only one
that i probably have like a little bit
of qualms with is uh tokyo no
absolutely not this isn't a masterpiece
if we're talking about overrated films
tokyo drift uh it is not overrated
listen the main actor you know his
entire fast and furious franchise i've
ever written he's actually i said he's
he's an impeccable character actor the
main actor in tokyo drift you know i
don't know if you're being serious he
he he enveloped like he nothing is
mimicked living in japan quite like
tokyo drew you're right you're right
when i went to school and some and you
know i love all one japanese actors in
this you know
you know when i was in school in japan
with my black friend from america um
we dreamed of going to japan one day and
we were like what is the closest we can
get to it
you know
i think every every single point of
tokyo drift is a master class in
filmmaking frankly uh from the very
start you know in the american high
school scene it's very very much like
how to still be in america yeah and
naturally i race my cars and uh i cause
a lot of damage and don't get arrested
and get exiled which i don't think is a
punishment that you see
you know a lot of movies they would just
arrest him yeah and i think he was
really genius well you know like
excellent full speed drifting through a
parking lot which is just you know if
you've ever been to a parking lot in any
country it's just impossible there's not
enough movies that use exile as a as a
good way of
conveying the story
name a movie with exile in it i'll wait
there we go
for good reason it's a medieval concept
that it hasn't been introduced in modern
films you know
exile exile he was exiled from arkansas
some i don't know where the [ __ ] he was
i don't know some hick town yeah and you
know his accent is just amazing i love i
love this guy's accent so so much i love
the accent i don't think i've ever felt
physical pain while watching a movie
before until i launched youtube i'm
gonna be honest i have not seen a single
fast and furious film uh i've only seen
tokyo drift and i you know because i
didn't wanna i didn't wanna be annoyed
because we'd already found the best fast
and furious film so why watching i must
say you are not missing out on it no no
tokyo have you watched your drift i i
literally just said five seconds ago
literally five seconds i think it was a
fast and furious film no i don't count
this as a foster future it's a cinema
experience it's a totally different it's
somehow worse no it's
it's if you add up all the imdb scores
of the fast and furious films it's still
not as high as tokyo direct like
yeah because like zero zero zero
there's not much
tokyo drift is a great film uh that is
close to my heart um in many ways uh not
only did it get me into uh donkey kong
uh because of the dk oh yeah of course
yeah
this is the monkey origin story
there was
you know it's almost
it's just there's nothing quite as uh
groundbreaking as this film quite
frankly
so what what's your favorite scene uh i
like the scene
where
he breaks his ipod and then he still
manages to sell the ipod broken and then
he doesn't check to he doesn't check to
to check the ipod before buying it uh i
believe this is what happens and then he
purchased the ipod then gets annoyed
that it was broken yeah but he never
once thought i should check this ipod
before buying it uh class and that's
just a great i thought that was a really
intelligent scene because that's how
they made conflict through a broken ipod
what i want to know is um how there's so
many fast and the furious films uh well
you this actually saved the fast and
furious franchise
i
when you hear of someone saying fast and
furious i think of tokyo drift yeah
they're right most people i think think
of tokyo drift and i'm like why like do
the other fast and furious films even
have names how does it like
how does such a [ __ ] film become so
iconic like that's what i wanted like
just like it is
it is terrible by every single metric of
the english word but i love this film to
death it's like the room right
it's like the room of fast and furious
because
it's just it's just got the coolest name
i mean tokyo drift right it's a [ __ ]
cool last one so literally i know we
spoke about this before but like it was
kind of like a gateway for me to japan
like yeah it goes actually it kind of
legit got me into japan in many ways i'm
sorry it was it was better
it's great because then i got to learn
actual [ __ ] all right
also it was the very first dvd i ever
owned uh it was totally fair enough yeah
it's in a glass cabinet as you can
imagine i think that i think i think the
vacuum sealed yeah
yeah mint condition has been graded
obviously
i think the first dvd i ever owned was
shrek
well honestly okay so tokyo drift is a
terrible but amazing movie and i can
watch it and enjoy it because you can
just laugh at it now it's amazing to
laugh at oh yeah
there's some of the dialogue that they
that those poor actors have to actually
like say it's just hilarious yeah and
then it gets just not not fun at all
towards the end right and then it
becomes two different okay
then it becomes too soon let me ask you
one thing all right why shrek two over
strike one two is the most straight
straight two stretch two is the best
really it is dude two is the best bro
shrek two is the best like like shrek
run set the rules and then what is your
friend your english shrek one set the
rules and then shrek two perfected
everything yeah
okay look i'm not gonna go against the
fact that shrek two is a good movie
strike two is the best bro but prince
charming is [ __ ] amazing i still
think shrek 1 is battle
shrek 1 is just an encapsulated
experience that is fantastic i think the
problem with shrek 1 is that no one can
watch it seriously anymore because it's
being memed to the ends of the earth not
enough not enough scenes in shrek to
have been memed and i think that's why
two is just like i actually disagree
because i feel like shrek is one of the
few franchises where the memes have only
like put it into legendary status i am
never going to forget shrek anymore yeah
yeah i can't like that's why
smash mouth can like retire because
they've already been immortalized yeah
through shrek memes strength is an
amazing film that you can watch anytime
but i think people forget how [ __ ]
amazing shrek 2 is yeah
obviously so much better than track one
watch it in my opinion like shrek one
just inches strike is an 8.5 and shrek
is a nine point two in my head trick two
sorry two there's a nine point five and
shrek one is uh eight point five sorry
honestly
every single character they oh two it's
not even worth watching every single
character they introduce in shrek 2 is a
banger character true they all like help
the story so much and then they they
build on the the one-off characters in
shrek 1 that you thought were a joke
yeah they bring them back they're like
hold up hold up you know there's a
reason why the wharf is cross-dressing
let's find out let's just see
gingerbread man in pinocchio also uh
they use uh the soundtrack uh in very
intelligent ways you know they do they
do the soundtrack's banging yeah yeah
that's true
the condition of i need a hero was yeah
[Music]
standalone movie was terrible
but there's a reason why he was so
lovable it's also amazing to think like
how many [ __ ] high-profile actors are
in shrek 2. honestly isn't it isn't the
very godmother played by julie andrews i
think so i think yeah if you're if you
want your career made you're in shrek
too yeah every coincidence that every
single shrek 2 actor is a goddess
antonio banderas was the cat right yeah
exactly right
why did mike myers do another like
[ __ ] yeah yeah austin powers film
when he was in shrek yeah this is why i
even tried yeah why why why joey
the best minecraft shrek 100 because
mike myers has like two good films and
uh it's shrek
shrek
wayne's world is overrated track one and
two is only good role i agree i'll agree
wayne's world is over right now yeah
okay uh but let's talk about the the
quentin tarantino choice you put yes
kill bill i i think volume one really
okay i like volume really
i i actually won number one
i know volume is great volume 2 is rated
higher and it's a crime we didn't get
another one it's a legit crime we didn't
get a volume 3. uh i just think
i think in the entire like filmography
of queen tarantino
kill bill is just one that i just forget
see the thing for me is like pulp
fiction isn't even like my top five
quentin tarantino really yeah i think
that like glorious bastards django is
better um
is better than pulp fiction and what
else has he done that's bad what about
like jackie brown look look look
maybe
django would have been like one of his
best films if not for jamie foxx i feel
like jamie foxx was so [ __ ] dry do
you know who was originally casting
smith will smith they got wilson's for
that movie
[Music]
yeah christoph waltz had to do the
[ __ ] yeah yeah exactly everyone is
i think jimmy fox is great in that movie
what do you remember after the big scene
in the middle uh i think i actually
can't remember much that's that's the
point
because after that it's jamie foxx who
has to carry the film and he just
doesn't well i think one of the actually
one jamie foxx tries when the [ __ ]
deck is samuel jackson what i was gonna
say because i was gonna say like
actually like you know everyone focused
on christoph waltz he did amazing and so
did uh uh leonardo dicaprio yeah yeah
but like samuel jackson is like probably
one of the my favorite things in that
film he's he's so [ __ ] good he's good
evil yeah he's good don't get me wrong
but it's not the best samuel jackson
role
[ __ ] role he does is amazing like
samuel jackson kills it and everything
yeah yeah i get that but like i think
his role in like jackie brown was 100
times better
i just i just think i had more fun
watching one like jackie brown and like
even kill bill over django
i i just i don't think pulp fiction was
that good
how dare you
wow yeah i think it was fine there was
just like there was too many scenes
where i was actually bored during pulp
fiction
like i the scene when they're at the
restaurant just talking it was i was
bored out of my mind what you mean the
one at the end no no in the start and
the start
not right not the diner the restaurant
where they're like uh were they doing
like milkshakes with john travolta oh
jack rabbits yeah i can't [ __ ] that
seems [ __ ] great i just think john
travolta is like not a good actor i i
think he's not good i mean i don't know
if one of these mistakes though no john
is a badass no no okay john travolta is
very much samuel jackson carries like
you it's so obvious because when samuel
jackson isn't withdrawn to walter
johnsonville sucks okay in my opinion
john scenes were there without those two
together yeah well there weren't many
like one or two but like and he was
terrible i think john travolta is
terrible but john travolta is one of
those actors where like
i feel have you seen his recent movies
no but that's because okay the reason
why recent john travolta movies he's
clearly like has just been type casted
as the bad guy because of pulp fiction
because before pulp fiction
john travolta just did all the grease
lightning movies right so he literally
went further he was in greece he
literally went from this like sing-songy
like
so suddenly playing as this like badass
gangster right and because of the
success of pulp fiction all the movie
industry was like we need a bad guy
who's also like kind of quirky and
charming on the surface but is actually
[ __ ] up on the inside john travolta i
mean like pulp fiction isn't my favorite
tarantino movie
i mean i put it on his reservoir
like i i still would put like i i really
love glorious bastards yeah um would you
saying glorious masters is better than
pulp fiction do you do you
i'd say it's about the same
i think glorious bastards is good it's
better than pulp fiction but for
different reasons yeah i i do agree with
you where there are some parts of pulp
fiction that did drag but when like i
feel like the highs of pulp fiction are
just they're like the best tarantino can
do yeah uh kill bill is i feel like one
of his most i love different movies yeah
kill build is clearly the movie where
tarantino was like i like anime by the
way yeah i love it
i really like anime i really like japan
it's so cool i just love it everything
about the movie is just so fun i mean
like yeah yeah
is [ __ ] awesome
i love the scene with uh uh what's the
name kuriyama who did gogo hibari with
like the chain thing that's so good i
love that i just love [ __ ]
when like um
goku kibara comes out like swinging the
the that sucks and then turns around
she's like go go danny
that scene [ __ ] kills me every time
yeah i mean i feel like on an aesthetic
level there's a few that are as iconic
as kill builds
[ __ ] and also uh the restaurant is
still like open in tokyo yeah yeah yeah
like going there and like seeing it and
be like [ __ ] yeah it's so cool when
you go to that restaurant you're also
like [ __ ] how did they make this happen
it's definitely like a culturally
significant movie i mean i mean like
for the record all of quinton tarantino
movies are [ __ ] amazing
uh i just feel like kill bill is like
the most different i feel like
especially in terms of tarantino movies
volume two was felt me way more like a
tarantino movie either i dead ass don't
even remember what happens in volume two
she [ __ ] kills bill joey
joey how do you spoil joey i can't
believe it's spoiled kill bill it's
literally literally there in the title
i've re-watched the first one so many
times i've barely watched the second one
i don't know why i don't know it's just
like i've definitely seen kill bill
volume 2 a couple of times i just don't
remember what happened other than the
titular i mean i would say that the only
film i mean the only seeing out kill
bill that really sticks out to my mind
is the one at the end of kill bill
volume one which is her against that's
oh lucy lou right
no not lucy liu the one with her against
like the [ __ ] what the name of the uh
gang that she fights
that's not the end the crazy 88 yeah
that's like in the middle no that's like
right before the end right before the
end is when she he she fights lucy liu
yeah that's the ending yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so the one so she fights the
crazy 88 before she
to me that is like the iconic scene of
the kill build
but i feel like overall i feel like the
second film was just a little bit better
um i felt like i have to rewatch it
honestly yeah i have to i think so what
why is this your favorite tarantino
movie then i don't know again i think
it's just how unique it is and how
stylized like this i don't you don't
really get a movie like it anymore i
don't know yeah definitely not it's just
such a good movie i feel i feel like
this is the only successful live-action
anima adaptation you know what i mean
where it's like this feels like it was
based off of i know you had actual
[ __ ] anime in it yeah
oh yeah
by production yeah yeah that's [ __ ]
badass yeah
the whole law when they build it up yeah
yeah yeah oh my god it's just so [ __ ]
up
everything about that film is just like
him just like just saying hey guys i'm a
weeb and like you said but yeah but but
in a good way yeah in a way that you're
like okay it's definitely done from like
a place of like respect yeah yeah
it's just it's just like you you watch
this and you just feel like this is just
fun yeah it's great this is just a
director having [ __ ] things it's
definitely the most like turn your brain
off type of time but it's the best kind
it's the best
because you don't need to turn your
brain off to appreciate this movement
yeah but at the same time it's that it
follows that kind of same style yeah
where you don't have to think much but
everything about this just has impact
yeah absolutely right impact impacts i
definitely agree kill bills
i just want to re-watch it now honestly
it's been a while um
boys honestly honestly i i know you put
this on because you thought that we i
was going to like
rub or just [ __ ] destroy you for it
but i'm glad someone put adam sandler
listen click i love okay 100 percent
easily the best adam sandler film okay
okay like a film made by adam sat this
is made by him right like i think so
yeah yeah dude click is so good clink is
a really
really good movie
i still cry at the end of click every
single goddamn actually i was like
family
that's all i can remember i was really
really close to putting uh 50 first
dates on my own
no click is actually good
click is one of those movies that gets
so much bad rap but like i actually
think it's like come on it's pretty it's
pretty [ __ ] it's a very it's handler
has a bad rap but of course there's some
there's some scenes in there you're like
all right adam come on yeah but then
there's also so many moments you're like
holy [ __ ] this is actually like a a
really good [ __ ] take on
your life and and missing out on yeah
especially the second half where it
starts to get really serious i'm just
like oh my god this is not the direction
i was expecting it to go so good yeah
like it shows that like when adam
sandler wants to [ __ ] act he brings
his [ __ ] name i was like wow he
he can act
again this is like why watching uncut
gems is like all the [ __ ] parts of click
are like not there right and just just
great [ __ ] acting from adam sandler
and like it's just it's amazing
i just feel like people forget that i
think adam sandler actually made good
films i i i like a lot like like i feel
like click was might might be his like
last great film or last good film
because i remember he just like fell off
a cliff after a certain point but
now he just makes he's openly admitted
that he makes movies on um basically if
he can go to a vacation on the
place because his production what a
powerful thing because the movies that
he makes his production companies yeah
so he just picks places he can go on
vacation
i think there's a lot of good adam
sandler movies that i really enjoy like
uh has anyone seen anger management yeah
i've really really enjoyed something
jack nicholson
oh my god that's such a good film that's
a great one like he has such a bad rep
but i [ __ ] these like his films
defined a lot of like the early 2000s
comedy i
so [ __ ] stupid like in a bed bath
beyond he gets
like he's like yeah he's like a security
guard bed bath and beyonce there's so
many [ __ ] childish jokes like when he
farts on the guy and stuff and then fast
forwards in the room like that's just so
dumb because like they actually hit so
many good [ __ ] emotional notes
i wish they didn't [ __ ] sully with
that [ __ ] but it's actually a good movie
i love it it's so good although to be
fair the scene where he like smacks the
boss in the face and then plays and
there's like whoa i just had a massive
headache like that scene is still really
funny yeah yeah there's some good moves
okay
i have never seen catch me if you can
you haven't no oh my god it's a movie
it's so good it's a movie i've heard so
many times i think it is the best lean
out of the capri film yeah that's all
i've heard from people and then there's
tom hanks in it as well i mean i mean
tom hanks is just a [ __ ] delight yeah
i mean i i feel like it's
what do you think is when you think
leonardo dicaprio what movie comes to
your mind i i don't think i'll catch me
if you can no
i think tom hanks for this one yeah i
don't think of him for it but then also
when i think of it it uses like
everything that leonardo dicaprio
especially at that point in his life
actually what movie do you think of when
you say leonardo dicaprio probably now
wolf of wall street yeah i think
now oh really i think it's shutter
yeah i feel like leonardo dicaprio has
evolved quite a lot during his time
because he's been acting since like
remember when he remember when he was
the titanic boy yeah right nobody knew
him for anything else but titanic but
like i feel like when he did this movie
it like perfectly
captured at that age what he was best at
doing was playing like the sexy young
guy yeah and he's so [ __ ] good in
this movie and i love it
i could if you need to watch this movie
it's no no i do it's this is one of
those movies that i've heard people
talking about for years now yeah and
i've just never found and it's based on
a true story i like the guy the guy the
biopic and the guy is the guy who is
actually based on has done like google
talks now and about how he i think he's
done work he said he did like work for
the fbi afterwards
i think he was in this movie or at least
he was a producer yeah because like i
have i've purposely like not looked into
this film because i feel like i just
want to go into a blind yeah just watch
it they got it's such a good story and
although obviously it's dramatized it is
based on a real event and it's so good
because like if i was to actually do a
three by three with like my top favorite
movies of all time there would
definitely also be a tom hanks movie in
there oh dude my castaway would be like
i i had only seen castaway recently and
it it was one of the few movies
yeah i only saw it recently right um but
it was one of the few movies where
despite how much hype had gone into it
yeah i thought it was as good yeah it
lived up to everything it's i thought it
was an amazing [ __ ] film amazing if
you can is more of a leonardo dicaprio
film than a tom hanks film i feel like
it's half and half
to me it's two big names yeah it's two
very big names and i feel like yeah it's
it is leonardo dicaprio he he does do
really well in it and i feel like it
just him and tom hanks it's it's both of
them in that film where with castaways
tom hanks and uh what's the other
[ __ ] massive tom tom hanks film that
green mile not green mile green mile's
also good
mom yeah he plays the main security
guard he's incredible
uh forrest gump oh [ __ ] what a what
an amazing film no that would probably
be like in my heart also saving private
ryan as well yeah yeah yeah
he's everything he's in he's good toy
story hello anything
anything that man is in is a good film
yeah yeah
yeah i just feel like he's the world's
dad i don't know like so
tom hanks this is daddy [ __ ] kidding
me oh my god i feel like we should
explain some of the plots of these stars
i'm sure i just feel like these are such
like big movies there everyone should
know them
if you can if you haven't seen it uh
it's about a guy who uh pretends to be a
pilot
and that's it that's literally it and
the about a detective trying to find him
that's not what it's about oh it's kind
of it it's what i don't want to i don't
want to spoil too much yeah yeah don't
go too into i don't want to give you
more information i just know it's a
[ __ ] amazing film and i need to watch
it that's like i mean it's that but it's
not but just watch it like it's that's
it
[Laughter]
that's like that's like saying like
sixth sense is about a divorce
i mean
it's it's about it's the real life story
of a con artist right that's pretty much
it
okay and then okay i appreciate the fact
that you put willy wonka in the
chocolate factory but the og one yeah
the og one the new one sucks yeah the
new one i think it's got its 50th
anniversary this year yeah damn already
yeah [ __ ] i just love this movie i can
want like as a from a young age to now
like [ __ ] gene wilder is like such a
goddamn good actor holy [ __ ] this
movie's good i mean it's it's also [ __ ]
his granddad bro [ __ ] his granddad
i mean it's a classic movie for a reason
right i mean um i've already mentioned
the truman show as well which is
my favorite jim carrey movie as well why
are there so many
like what are so many comedy actors like
that are just like actual just really
[ __ ] good actors understand emotions
well to be
like funny i think but jim carr is such
a [ __ ] good actor when he decides to
act sorry i feel sorry for that man he
seems like he has a lot of problems yeah
yeah but i feel like comedy actors
normally do have that problem i really i
really want to re-watch the truman show
now because i want to because the whole
the entire premise of the truman show is
that it's just
is it a twist can i spoil it i think
everyone knows what it is okay well you
don't want the twisters you should know
what the twist is yeah so it follows the
story of this guy whose entire life has
just been broadcasted it's just like
it's just his life is a reality they've
made a world around this man yeah to
make a tv show this was a black mirror
episode before black mirror was a thing
basically yeah yeah this is basically
just irl twitch before irl twitch was a
thing and now it is a thing but like
except that in the movie he doesn't want
to be filmed yeah but i will twitch
people like yeah let's do it okay so so
you you remember ludwig uh ludwig's
subathon just imagine that from like
birth but he didn't know yeah but he did
it
um but that's the truman show and it's
just a [ __ ] amazing great movie i'd
love to see the truman show except where
truman is just a horrible person because
truman is this is a nice guy yeah what
if truman did things that got him
canceled all the time you know would
people still watch the show with the
raiders go down how would they fix the
ratings if truman was going around just
gets canceled yeah just getting canceled
they're like [ __ ] we gotta we gotta
interfere we're gonna we gotta really
um and then we joked about no country
for old man yeah i [ __ ] love this
film it's a great film it's just one of
those films that's like yes i'm a movie
critic wow i think it's based on my list
that you could say that about me but i
do think that no country forward man was
the first film where i was like wait you
can just like make things this ambiguous
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
i mean like
it's also not easy as [ __ ] yeah i do
like my very uh kind of open-ended
ambiguous films you know memento was one
of them
you know you don't really have a film
where you follow the main character
often that that acts behaves in this
cold way yeah that you're also like
you're like come on tell me something
yeah and they just don't tell you
anything i just let you follow the other
film that's even remotely like that is
maybe like american psycho maybe yeah
yeah yeah but every single like you know
when you re-watch this movie so many
times and then you go and watch like
people watched it a lot yeah i've cause
it used to be on channel four all the
[ __ ] tv yeah i did didn't know so i
used to watch it all the [ __ ] time
like 10 ad breaks in between yeah but
like you know you'd watch this movie and
then you'd read about it yeah and you'd
be like oh that's what that was about
and then you go back and go and watch it
yeah oh [ __ ] i was exactly the same with
and i was debating when to put it on but
i was like no my three by three is
already pretentious
i was i was gonna put multiple and drive
oh my god oh my [ __ ] great film buddy
great film great films
david lynch is one of my favorite
directors i was like i don't want this
to be more pretentious that's what i was
thinking as well there's so many things
in no country for all men that i just
love so much this day like the fact that
he just decides sometimes to flip a coin
no i was i was to kill them yeah and he
went through with it like if it if he
genuinely went heads he wouldn't like it
wouldn't kill them and it's like holy
[ __ ] this man is insane yeah like i i've
gone through this like recent phase of
just like instead of watching movies
again i just rewatch clips from movies
and for some reason like because i watch
one another iconic clip gets recommended
and like i remember just re-watching the
gas station scene
yeah yeah yeah
holy [ __ ] what a good scene i think out
of like the entire history of movies in
terms of like tension i can't think of a
better scene than that i mean just such
a good actor as well i can't remember
the main man because he's done oh he did
he was the one of the villain in the
bond movies yeah yeah yeah but he's
terrifying yeah he's so good in this
eyes man i know right yes
cold-blooded eyes
every single
dialogue moment that he has with anyone
is just like oh my god it's [ __ ]
terrifying that's funny that's funny you
say you go back and like watch movie
clips of like iconic movies because i
have that exact thing with uh the
[ __ ] court scene and there will be
blood
where like daniel day lewis is like
doing that like insane monologue at the
courtroom and i'm like holy [ __ ]
i need to go back and watch this movie
but i can't be [ __ ] again i've
actually actually like there's there's
there's been the phase now where because
i've been watching a lot of movie clips
sometimes i just watch clips from movies
i haven't seen yeah yeah and then i end
up just psychopath huh psychopath
no because like it gets recommended and
like it's a good clickbait title i'm
like damn that was a good scene and then
i watched another clip and another clip
and i feel like there's a lot of people
doing this now because i go to the
comments section
i go to the comment section and it's
just like i feel like it's the person
it's people who have gone through the
exact same algorithm journey as me
because i remember going through the
comment section and it's just i feel
like i've watched this entire movie now
just through clips and i'm just like
that's just that's exactly what i did
those poor cinema directors yeah right
pour their heart out to make a cohesive
story that's well paid and you
[ __ ] go on youtube and watch
clips we're literally
yeah i [ __ ] love that movie like i
can re-watch it as many times yeah i
mean watch no country old man it's a
very good that's a great film or just
watch the gas station scene on youtube
no don't do that with the zero context
and just be very confused and be very
confused why this guy is asking this
other guy to flip a coin it's still a
great just it's still a great scene even
after the [ __ ] dialogue he asks
people is like the things he asks people
are so creepy the thing that stands out
to me in that film wasn't the dialogue
but it's when he puts down the candy
wrapper yeah and it just like expands
for like a little bit too long and i've
never i've never been so tense hearing
just a candy wrapper expand i'm just
like what the [ __ ] man it's also the
coolest weapon ever used in a movie yeah
oh yeah oh [ __ ] gas canisters yeah so
[ __ ] cool because you're like oh this
is badass but [ __ ] he's terrifying but
yeah yeah this is cool though really
scary i forgot tommy lee jones in that
movie as well yeah he's the main um guy
trying to get him right yeah yeah stuff
like the detective or police guy
whatever the sheriff yeah the sheriff
that's right yeah so then of course last
of all we've got uh ip man
one of the best if not the best martial
arts movie especially in the past yeah i
can agree with that yeah there's a lot
of i mean you know i'm sure a lot of
people who are massive martial arts buff
would argue there's a lot of the earlier
films like some of the gently early
stuff some of jackie chan's earlier
stuff this happened to gently he just
kind of disappeared she's kind of jetted
so far as far as i know
as far as the [ __ ] out so as far as i
know what happened with jet li is that
after fearless which was the 2008 yeah
which which i thought was a [ __ ]
amazing like he's supposed to be his
last that was supposed to be his last
like epic right um martial arts film and
uh it was kind of well received it was
it was it's like a very seven six out of
ten film all right i thought it was
really good i was it was actually like i
think it's really underrated for a
gentleman i mean his his older stuff is
just way better yeah i know
but in terms of modern stuff you know
and that was supposed to be his last one
and then what ended up happening was
that the expendables were like money um
so that was actually like that's right
so that was like that was like his last
action film and since then he kind of
said that as far as i know he kind of
quit doing uh big uh big martial arts
films yeah because i think it's just too
intense like it's a lot because you have
to remember those scenes like
choreograph is that insane
i just i just remember the [ __ ]
expendables movie like yeah i was like
talk about the most like wanker-ish
movie it's like let's just get as many
big people yeah
i actually watched it not too long ago
because you recommend yeah did you like
it yeah it's really [ __ ] good i mean
i love gently it's got one of my
favorite fight scenes there's any uh the
fighting the japanese and the karate
like ten of them and he's like back to
that scene i think it's like the best
one of the best [ __ ] martial art
scenes of all time
talking about clips you can rewatch on
youtube rewatched that yeah yeah
okay to be fair all right yeah that's
fair enough you can watch kung fu fights
but like you can't watch that scene for
no questions
it's so good it's just like so the story
of it man is uh it's about when uh japan
is invading uh china um way back and
then
i think there's a there's a scene where
uh but once they've invaded they're like
oh well you know japanese karate or
something is the superior so bring your
bring your chinese uh people to practice
with yeah
that's literally what it is it's like if
you win you get a bag of rice or
something yeah and he's like i'll take
on ten of you and okay it's kind of
cheesy but it is epic but it's so
[ __ ] epic and they like snaps their
legs doing it it's insane i feel that i
feel that that kind of cheesiness though
in martial arts films is what makes a
martial art yeah it totally is i feel
like it set this that scene alone it set
the stakes perfectly where it's just
like oh [ __ ] i'm ready to see him [ __ ]
[ __ ] up yeah and he just takes on ten
black belts
that's not even like the end of the film
though it's like halfway through yeah
but unless it's but it's the best fight
it's the best fight of the franchise
right because i remember when uh because
the previous guy he fought like three
black belts and he's like [ __ ] i'll take
on all of you and it's just it's just
one of the few moments in film where
you're just like
i'm ready for this man i i know this
would never happen yeah i i don't care
how cheesy this is
especially like when you're like
uh would you so when i was like 16 when
i was watching all these movies i just i
legitimately thought like martial arts
like badass and i'm like dude this is
epic but obviously now with all the you
know the mma fighters that like fought
them and yeah now it's not so epic
because you're like okay the mma
fighters should kill these guys but when
you're like 16 you think like oh [ __ ]
this is like the superior way of
fighting yeah yeah like this is epic oh
my god like it's so cool you strengthen
your speed and now yeah it's so [ __ ]
cool right
but yeah no not so much
but back then you're like oh my god this
is amazing yeah yeah there's a lot of
martial like uh gently uh gently's
earlier staff is amazing obviously
jackie chan's earlier cinema
cinemagraphy is amazing as well love
like drunken master and stuff like that
yeah such a good film
um what are some really good what's that
i forgot what jetley's high street film
is called it's this
1980s film it's really highly rated
uh is it fisted the dragon is it or
enter the end of the dragon or something
enter the dragons the bruce lee will oh
no sorry it's the
that's like his his like i think it has
like 100 percent of rotten tomatoes yeah
i say fist of fury but i'm pretty sure
it's bruce lee that's pissed
with uh jetley is a really good one but
yeah that's
it depends if you like martial arts film
where they use like wires like some
people don't like it when they do that
uh it's kind of up to you
right yeah yeah i kind of prefer it when
they're just like beating the [ __ ]
genre
i don't i know it has a name it's like a
firework why why why
it's not really martial arts but it is
martial arts yeah it's really good 2006.
i really liked hiro which had uh donnie
yen in it as well
yeah anjali the story's so [ __ ] cool
yeah i i think that story i feel like i
haven't really sat down and watched like
a lot of jet li films his stuff is
actually like really [ __ ] good
because daddy and donald uh hasn't have
oh another one i think it's called uh it
might be called war or like warrior or
something it's like uh it's about like
the three kingdoms or something in china
way back oh yeah like sangokshi warrior
yeah what is it called i think it's
called warrior might be called what just
warrior
and it's such a good fight
yeah jetta is the main character and uh
it's like this uh
about how like a general uh got like i
don't want to spoil it but you should
watch it it's really fun
really really [ __ ] good and i feel
like um because i i didn't want to put
another martial arts film on uh
my three by three but i feel like one of
the few things southeast asians can be
proud about are our [ __ ] martial arts
films because you know like the raid
yeah
yeah pretty pretty much the only thing
of thai culture that's ever been like
popularized outside you know
um but yeah like i like i was you know
really happy to see like the
the wrong light is this
martial art films you know
you think of like you know it man it's
more like very clean the raid's really
[ __ ] good raids
indonesian right yeah it's indonesia but
directed by a welsh guy oh really it's a
wash guy who directs oh [ __ ] right yeah
it's that the raid one or raid two i
think because i know you've donated raid
to raid
who directed right one and two can you
check real quick i swear that's another
thing i've heard of that i've never seen
the raid
the raid one is like such a good premise
yeah yeah just get to the top of an
apartment building yeah that's it it's
it's it's basically just a fighting game
it's basically just like double dragon
yeah it's just double dragon just
like the fighting's like the
choreography is insane yeah gareth evans
yeah
the most welsh name on it
literally two welsh names got off the
name
fair enough it's like it's so bizarre
there's a welsh guy directing an
indonesian film oh yeah i do but it's
just like awesome like it's such a good
fight some cross-cultural pollination
look at us ty and while she here too
but yeah i mean i yeah i [ __ ] love
fighting uh martial arts movies yeah
i've watched nearly all of gently's
films i think i've watched most of them
i couldn't watch some of the older ones
because they were impossible to find
online right um and i've watched i think
all of donnie yen's films pre-ap man
i haven't watched it man four i heard it
was okay i've really liked it band four
really
yeah i actually it's my second favorite
maybe i'll watch it tonight because uh
because i feel like ip man four is just
three was the worst yeah i feel like if
man four was just it man two done better
yeah because my problem with it man two
is that the villain is just so comical
that i just couldn't take him seriously
let's characterize this character so the
whole selling point to like a western
audience of uh ipman was just that it's
the guy who trained bruce lee yeah
that's literally the selling point of
that yeah fair enough but he's supposed
to be like a master or something yeah i
don't know i i mean that is a cool like
catch to be i mean that's
again i don't know how how true it is
but it's an interesting
made-up story maybe if it is i don't
know if it's real or not
it's true it's a real character but the
events are fictional yeah
that's normally how it goes yeah with
martial arts people it's kind of hard to
survive some of the [ __ ] yeah
but i mean like i'm sure they fought all
those people but they probably died
halfway through yeah i mean i don't i
don't think you did fight 10 black belts
no no that's uh that's yeah probably uh
probably dramatized unless he's like a
[ __ ] super saiyan but yeah there's
another donnie yen film that's actually
really good where he's like a detective
in a small town
uh i think in a village
and it's really good because it's like a
mystery of the martial arts and it's
just yeah it's pretty good i've got what
it's called again i've watched these
movies so long ago yeah it came after it
man same with jackie chan as well some
of his best works are when he was young
like [ __ ] police story
story is fantastic is that the scene
where he jumps on the wire yeah yeah
yeah it is completely real what's it
called what do you think about
flashpoint might be flashpoint yeah
i think it's flashpoint what's the po is
it yellow the poster the yellow one is
oh uh
oh wait uh we have the
chinese name it's the one where he's a
teacher right
maybe again i might have remembered it
incorrectly because it's been so much
big brother i have to go back to the
thing and watch it i might be
misremembering i feel like one
underrated donnie yen film is i think is
spx or something like that what's he
what's the plot i i honestly i do not
remember but i the only reason sps just
sounds like a law firm
let me let me because what happened was
that all right you're jack you're bruce
lee then you heard jackie chan and then
when jackie chan was getting older jet
li was making films yeah and then when
jetley was getting all that donnie yen
came in but i don't really know who it
is now who's like the main martial arts
guy
who is the main like face of martial
arts i don't even know him
but he's supposed to retire yeah i think
he still is done again because he's in
the the new marvel film yeah but they
also don't really utilize him much i
mean he's the i mean he's the villain
isn't it i feel like i feel just like
martial films of kind of just like a
little bit of a dying breed almost in
like especially in the west i feel like
i'm sure like you know if you go to asia
and south east asia they're still making
well i mean the past well the past like
20 years have all been from china like
right it manages from uh china right
yeah um and then donnie yen is in rogue
one uh from star wars but again when i
was watching that movie and you could
see what donnie yen does yeah i'm kind
of disappointed because you're like
donnie ann is such a was so [ __ ] good
and they barely use him he just swings a
[ __ ] thing around yeah oh cool he's
blind
yeah a lot of people could have done
what donaian did in that film and i feel
like why if you're getting donnie yen
and he did he doesn't really speak much
in the film right because he i don't
think he can speak much english yeah so
all i'm saying is there hasn't been a
rush hour or two yet there hasn't been a
modern rush hour with johnny yeah yeah
honestly [ __ ] yeah and i i i i ice cube
stupid
[Music]
movie industry we just gave you a
million dollar idea donny in an ice cube
in rush hour
seven or whatever the next one is
oh my god i was thinking about what's sp
spl what that's the plot of that movie
can you tell me the plot spl well
[Music]
yeah but i um there's one fight scene in
spl in sbl which is like completely just
improvised yeah okay is it in the street
yeah it's in the street
and it's such a [ __ ] good fight scene
and you and then because
the whole premise around this the whole
background around this fight scene is
that they train together these two these
two actors uh donnie yen and i'm not
sure what the other person is but they
train together and because they were so
familiar with each other's fighting
style they literally just improvised
this fight scene with just so cool with
just this basic okay here's what's meant
to happen but let's just try to kill
each other and then let's just get it on
film
yeah that's so cool it's such a good
film as well
it prepares a police detective who's
suffering from cancer and about to
retire resorts to illegal means in order
to capture ruthless tribes
all i remember was there was a police
detective in it i'm just like
that's that's like it's it's either like
traditional like historical setting or
they're a police officer
of course like a neo-noir crime drama
um but i mean yeah like oh god how do
you like describe this three by three
it's like how did you describe any how
did you describe any three by three
you could describe mine pretentious film
creature yeah pretentious pretentious
full
oh love guilty pleasure
something with wood with p
yeah p
y p because
uh pretentious potential powerful
uh poop pouring yeah
um but yeah i guess those are our three
by threes i hope you uh get to watch
some interesting movies if you haven't
seen some of these uh yeah please go and
watch all the movies i have some movie
recommendations that i will be watching
i guess now yeah i've honestly come out
with this with some movie
recommendations and this was actually
obviously i i always always got time we
know what we're doing after this
remember
sit down
but no i mean like i it feels good to be
able to talk about movies because i feel
like i don't get to talk about movies a
lot even though like i've i kind of
realized whenever i talk about movies
i've seen a lot of movies and i feel
like you guys have seen a lot of movies
as well and we even like off camera we
don't really talk about movies in
general i think i think it just has to
do with the fact that we haven't really
had time to just sit down and watch
something i've not watched movies in a
while yeah it's gotten i feel like i
don't know i feel like people don't
watch as many movies anymore yeah yeah
like if it's not on netflix then i
probably haven't seen it but i'd say i
watched like 90 of the films i've seen
in like between the ages of like um
18 and 14. yeah
i think that's usually like the period
in your life i'm gonna watch a lot of
movies when i discovered you could
google the movies and i was like holy
[ __ ]
yeah i mean my dad used to collect like
a shitload of dvds when like blockbuster
was still a thing so like i just watched
a lot of the movies with my dad yeah i
mean i i watch a lot less movies than i
do
than i did before as well because now
it's just all been replaced by anime
right and uh a lot of anime movies
and youtube as well yeah but if you're
on youtube but i feel like if there's a
big enough movie then i probably have
seen it like i'm surprised no one put
any marvel movies here uh
who's [ __ ] cares about marvel i mean i
care about marvel i i'm just like
marvel's that one franchise where i'm
just like hello i'm a normal yeah it's
fun but it's not like i never like i'm
never like [ __ ] dude that made me think
something that made me like yeah if i'm
gonna watch it if i'm gonna watch this i
know i was like really [ __ ] invested
in infinity war end game i'll say that i
didn't i didn't even watch those two
end game was good but again it wasn't
like i thought it was amazing but it
wasn't like sent that maybe like when i
left the cinema
like a week later i don't think about
endgame well so i'm surprised no one put
john wick as well because i i thought i
was close
someone was going to put john wick on
john was just another one of those like
it's fun turn your brains out no no no
no no it's it's [ __ ] no oh no i'm not
saying it's a bad movie yeah john rick
is probably like my favorite action
series it's it's like in in the west
they have uh john wick and in the east
they have it man that's that's like
it man is just like the uh asian
equivalent of john wick dude man i just
i'm not man so i i it's holds a very
dear place in my heart when i except
i've watched all the john wick movies in
cinema yeah and like i've watched the
last one that came out alone and it was
the cinema was empty and i had like such
an amazing time watching that it was
like the last
bro it was just fun i got to put my legs
up on the chair in front of me i had all
my popcorn and i just got to enjoy it
bro so good it was such a good dude i'm
so excited for the next one
i've only seen the first john wick movie
the second one's amazing again it's like
it's it's one it's another one of those
like long list of movies that i hear
people talking about saying it's amazing
and i'm like all right i'll watch it i
shouldn't be i don't want to be too
normal so i didn't put it on but it's
yeah because sometimes i just don't know
what movies to watch because i i don't
like it's weird now because i don't know
where to start because you know we're so
ingrained in like anime culture that i
know you know when there's a hot anime
coming out but in terms of movie
recommendations anything from like the
past five years if it's not been a lot
talked about a lot then i just probably
haven't tried i mean i barely have
enough time to watch anime little and
[ __ ] movies joey you don't watch
anime period no i don't
i don't watch movies period i don't
watch anime that's just how it goes just
just read that's free manga
manga and red porn you know who does
watch movies joey who you tell me is it
the patrons it is the page hell yeah bro
look at all these moviegoers let us know
uh on the reddit i guess i i mean i
don't even have to tell you guys to
[ __ ] do it because you probably will
just fill up our subreddit with your
three by threes yeah please do so uh
because we want to see what you guys i
think now that because we have mods in
the subreddit uh we're gonna have like a
dedicated thread for your movie three
threes and uh if you have any movie
recommendations i'm actually all open
ears oh absolutely like to me watching
movies is
my down time because i just i i can
watch it and i don't have to think about
making a video on it exactly i can just
watch it to enjoy it exactly it's just
like
to me with movies is how i feel other
people are anime where i'm just looking
for some good movies yeah so any movies
that have come out recently that you
might recommend if you have any
recommendations please because i've been
pretty out of touch with the movie scene
tell us gamers tell us your favorite
movies yeah tell us down in the comments
below also uh if you like the show then
consider supporting us on our patreon
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
give us your three by threes on the
subreddit and if you had our faces
listen to us on spotify
but uh yeah hopefully you guys enjoyed
this themed episode yeah
there's gonna be more three by threes
coming i'm just gonna say that right
it's gonna be a lot more three by three
it's gonna be a lot more throughput
through coming so if you like this kind
of episode then uh stick around for more
i mean it's just it's just an easy
format isn't it it really is but uh
until next time bye
[Music]
you